the time being 9 30 I call the public
hearing on House Bill 1032 local to
order and recognize the prime sponsor
representative Hugh I hope I said that
right
thank you Mr chairman and uh I want to
thank the honorable members of the
committee for making the travel today
and coming out
to hear me
excuse me
um I'll start off by giving you a little
bit of a background on this particular
I represent uh Laconia New Hampshire
and in Laconia we have a piece of
property that is known as the state
school property it's owned by the state
and it has been there for quite some
time it uh a bunch of years ago it used
to be the state school which housed
um
folks who needed uh mental supervision
and and help
um it's since been decommissioned and
it's just been sitting there so our town
very diligently
tried to get some sort of say in what
happens to the disposal of this property
there was a commission developed called
the Lakeshore Redevelopment commission I
do believe and that was uh created in
2017.
and that was to take folks from all
different sides
um of of uh government and and private
to try and decide what might be a good
idea and how to work with this uh
property as far as what I might need it
had the ability I believe to make get
grants there were many studies done to
see what needed to be done to the
property to be able to convey it
um that was all fine and it also gave
Laconia a voice into what might be done
with the property
um they uh had uh one at least one uh
person on that commission that was uh
appointed by uh the the citizens of
Laconia the city council and I think
there was one or two others that were
from Belknap County
what happened was is hb2 came around and
as you know how hb2 went
um
it's an ominous Bill and in an Omnibus
Bill things get put in and there was a
piece that was put in and I believe uh
you you have this in front of you it has
the governor's submission house version
and final version of of the bill
it basically
gave the entire authority to dispose of
the property to the governor and the
now
the reason I wrote the Bill is because
everybody had been working very
diligently to try and make an equitable
and fair
decision as to what to do with the
property
um when this occurred that took
laconia's voice right out of the picture
this literally sits within the city it
always has been it's a fantastic part uh
a piece of property
it is a budding a state park it's a
budding a sports complex
um
and the citizens of Laconia are
concerned as well as even Belknap County
that something may go there that just
isn't what they want
um you know in theory you could put
anything there you could put a garbage
dump you could put a high-tech uh
Business Park
but it should be at least since it's in
their backyard they should at least have
some sort of voice
the committee conference came around
um
we tried to to remedy this it got put
back to to this language and that was
the end of it I'm a new legislator I
didn't realize it I had one more chance
at trying to make this right so I'm here
today with this there was no public
hearing there was no input I would dare
don't understand the process of the um
Committee of conference or any of that
so it just happened and now Laconia is
without say
um
my bill is very crisp it's very clean
um it just uh repeals what was done in
hb2
and I want to point out one of the
things that is very important is
this will revert back to what was
already in place and I'd hand handed
this out to every I think everybody got
a copy and if not I have more this is um
title one uh the state and its
government
and it gives the powers and it's uh
section 440 acquisition and disposal of
real estate section one I just want to
point out it says um
Dupont upon determination that the
property is no longer needed by the
state the governor and Council shall
first offer it to the town city or
county in which the property is located
this folks would give Laconia
at least a chance in a say in what goes
on in their backyard and with that I'll
I'd be happy to answer any questions if
I can
um thank you are there questions from
representative
representative Huff um it's my knowledge
that they look City of Laconia already
uh had the opportunity to make an offer
on that property is that correct
any further questions I I would want to
clarify all you are asking for is that
we delete
what was done in House Bill 2 which did
have public hearings in both the house
and the Senate
um
and revert back to the Redevelopment
commission or just the normal process
for people to sell the property
it does both
um on this on the last part the
Redevelopment commission never had the
authority to do anything with that it
was just an uh an information gathering
and I believe it was it had the ability
to apply for Grants to like find out how
groundwater was what the infrastructure
of the buildings were on that that type
of thing I believe they did get quite a
few uh dollars to have that checked into
yes those are open to the public but
I've I feel fervently
that that process is not this process
this process I think is far more
important you have actual committee
hearings
where your elected officials here can
make this decision possibly go to the
floor go to the whole thing the other
one
you guys know how that goes I'm not a
big fan of it and and I I know that
in essence there's public hearings but I
would just submit that nobody in the
public was probably quite aware of it so
I just feel that this would be you know
a decent shot at that thank you
any further questions
representative Thompson
thank you Mr chairman um
representative did
you said they they've done some
investigations as to the groundwater and
and I'm sure contamination in the
buildings and that is the city willing
to absorb those costs should they be
able to buy this property
that I don't know
um I know that
there has been talk about what can be
done there what may be done there
um
as far as what the city is willing to do
they would have to you know go through
their process and decide this is just
what I wanted to do was just give them
an opportunity
so if for example say the powers that be
the the the council and whatnot decide
that they want to do something and they
have a legitimate buyer or somebody
that's interested they can at least make
the same offer to the town now the town
may decide that they don't want anything
to do with it and that that might be the
best thing but I just wanted to give
them that shot okay
thank you very much thank you
thank you
[Music]
if if this legislation prevailed that
there would be a time limit for Laconia
to to make a
a decision on whether to move forward
with it with something that they had in
mind or not
I don't believe that there's a time
limit because it's still in the hands of
uh the executive Council and the
governor as far as being able to
to execute
a purchase in sales
so it really is just they would have an
opportunity to at least look at it and
and if they thought it was good they
could maybe match it if they thought it
wasn't you know again it's just it's
purely about giving the folks there a
real opportunity to have a say in this
um the only other pink card that I have
welcome
better
we are being live streamed and so you
need to make sure that the red light is
showing
very good
thank you good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee thank you for
giving the opportunity to speak I'll be
brief there are a couple of bills in
front of you to talk a little bit
to the sale of that property where most
of you know if you don't our 911 psap is
located on that property currently we
want to make sure that we have eyes on
what's happening at the legislative
level I do have some comments but I
think in as I'm seeing the next bill
coming up we're probably more in tune to
having those comments heard then with
our partners at Lakes Region Mutual fire
rate as well so if it pleases the
chairman and the members of the
committee I can withhold those comments
until then
and that would be fine because I know
what you're going to be what to talk
about
and with uh
consent of the committee will hold off
the questions for for dos until we hear
the next bill
and I would like to call forward the
there it is thank you very much Mr
chairman
um and I hadn't planned on testifying
but I noticed a couple of questions have
come up in regards to the intentions of
the City of Laconia so for the record my
name is Andrew Hosmer I'm the mayor of
the City of Laconia and prior to my time
being mayor I served in the Senate and
worked on this particular piece of
property in the City of Laconia because
it's very important to us it's well over
200 Acres that the state used as the
Laconia characterized it was called the
Laconia state school
for almost 100 years it was for the
developmentally disabled it was gifted
to the state
over 100 years ago and meant for this
specific purpose as time has gone on and
we've changed our approach in the state
as to how we
care for a treat
those in the developmentally disabled
community
that facility was closed after after
being closed it was then used as a state
prison
it was there's an awful lot of barbed
wire and high fencing and lights and
that is still on the property right now
many of the buildings were renovated to
accommodate holding of prisoners
so what we have on this piece of land is
some of the most beautiful land really
in the state of New Hampshire and
certainly the most beautiful parcel of
land in the City of Laconia that is
undeveloped at this point but it's also
has a a dozen buildings or so that are
very old some of them are contaminated
many of them are falling down many it
was just abandoned by the state and so
when you drive by this land you see the
blighted and the Beautiful
we in the City of Laconia have always
looked at this land as something that is
part of the fabric of our community
though we didn't officially own it we
longed for the day that we could have
some influence on what was done with the
land first and foremost clean it make a
determination what level of remediation
the land would need because of some
toxic substances in the buildings as
well as the soil
and then second of all what would the
residents of the City of Laconia like to
see on this beautiful 200 Acres you know
the last thing we'd like to see at any
point in time is the Prime real estate
developed along the thoroughfares Route
106 and the buildings that really need
attention just left to continue to
crumble upon themselves obviously like
the rest of the State of New Hampshire
we have a housing issue we do not have
enough housing for people who live and
work want to live there but work in the
area
so we have worked closely for many years
trying to get this property first of all
cleaned
renovated some of the buildings
demolished we made an offer on the
property the city did maybe upwards of
12 years ago which was
rejected for all intents and purposes Mr
chair the property was then offered for
significantly less than the city offered
to the county and the county was in no
position to purchase it at that point so
this has really gone through a lot of
twists and turns over the years
what we are fully supportive and have
had a tremendous working relationship
with the Lakeshore Redevelopment
commission which has been chaired by
George bald former Commissioner of Dread
Bob Cheney
who is very well experienced in the
development of the peas Authority and
they work instrumental in taking that
land at peace and making it into
productive economic Redevelopment land
so they are very involved in this the
city had it so when the commission was
created the city had an opportunity to
have representation and we had members
appointed there are to my recollection
four members on this seven-member
committee who are from Belknap County
over the course of the past four years
they've done tremendous work at
enhancing the value of the property by
delineating Wetlands making further
determinations about the level of
remediation needed they've also done
some great work and been successful in
getting grants to say if we were to
develop this land what do we need for
utilities for water
for infrastructure so the value a lot of
the variables an investor would look at
when considering purchasing the land
they've removed those variables which
enhances the value of the land
so certainly when this came about in hb2
last year we were surprised to see that
that the governor was moving in a rather
rapid fashion to
sideline the commission and go to sell
the property we worked very hard city
council and myself with the commission
to say wait a minute we're the
commission is doing its job we're right
on track here and the city is really
involved in in their work
unfortunately it didn't work out that
way in hb2 passed
but since that time what we have been
successful in doing is working with the
executive Council and getting a
resolution passed
the there was a contract that went out
to market the property we asked that the
city be included in any contract with a
marketing firm and we were included
thankfully thanks to commissioner Kenny
and commissioner warmington took the
lead on this we really appreciate it
which allows the city to have a good
collaborative relationship with the
Department of administrative services
and with um
any action that may take place there I
have met regularly with the commissioner
of administrative Services Charlie
arlinghaus just met with him
yet two days ago along with Jared nighan
who's a taking the lead and marketing
the property it's not was not our first
choice to proceed this way but in the
alternative we're in a position right
now where the resolution has been
adopted unanimously by the executive
Council to make sure the Laconia
citizens are included
we are in a very good relationship with
administrative services and how we're
being included in a number of important
discussions so I am neutral on this bill
but I wanted to give you a little bit of
background on representative Thompson I
water on the land or maybe pollution on
the land
and
one thing the city feels very strongly
about
is that
the state if there is any groundwater
issues or any remediation that needs to
be done it's as a result of the actions
of the state
and the city is really not in a position
to say well we're going to come in and
clean the land
that we believe that the state Perhaps
Perhaps polluted to some extent you know
I just don't think we're in a position
to shift that all onto the taxpayers and
we would rather see this move to private
hands put it on the tax rolls give us
some housing stock inventory and also
preserve some of the beautiful aspects
of this property that's longer than I
anticipated speaking and I thank you for
your Indulgence
um it's okay we have lots of time
I I fully expected more of the citizens
of Laconia to be here to to talk about
this but
willing to take questions
absolutely yeah
represent boys
thank you mayor Hosmer um as you know I
represent Laconia as well and it's my
understanding Matt the executive council
is working very closely with Laconia on
the property now
so
are you happy with the way things are
going
thank you for the question
representative borders and thanks for
your your leadership and a number of
issues in the city and I appreciate our
working relationship that we continue to
develop
um I am happy as I said it's not and I
know the council is happy with it as
well we have six members of the city
council it's not the way we anticipated
it would go but thankfully commissioner
arlinghaus and his team as well as our
executive Council has been incredibly
receptive to our perspective and our
concerns in the city so it's the best of
representative Faulkner
Mr chairman
um
a little bit about what control you if
the property were sold to a private
Enterprise what
continued role of a city might play
through
site plan review zoning Etc and uh is
that something you feel happy with or
comfortable with
thank you very much for your question
representative Faulkner uh we do we
think that in order for a developer to
be successful there they have to have
established a good working relationship
with the city because you're right we
have zoning and we have planning
whatever their plans are for any
development
we in the city are going to have an
opportunity to weigh in on that through
our zoning board and our planning
department and our planning board as
well so really um you know it's a
expensive it's it's a costly investment
for someone to go in there
um I think in order to ensure that they
get the most out of their investment if
they're going to develop the land is to
it would be foolish for them to not work
very closely with the City of Laconia
and maybe giving us some sense of what
they want to do and we can at least give
it an initial blessing if you will
um and saying you know this is the type
of development we would like to see
happen on this this valuable land so I'm
satisfied with our level we have
performance zoning in the city as well
so we've got some flexibility with our
zoning ordinances when we look at a
project that might be tremendous for our
economy great for our housing stock
we've got flexibility in zoning to to
make that happen and and we're fortunate
that we have that
representative McConkey
thank you Mr chairman thank you mayor
for being here
I have followed this with you in your
town since I first came in 2002.
so you have zoning in place you have
site plan in place
and if a potential developer were to
come along and they were to follow your
rules and regulations as printed
what other what other oversight would
your town require
is there some special and I'm just
asking uh is there some special Playbook
that they need to go above and beyond
what your regulations are
thank you for your question
representative McConkey I no it's not we
performance zoning allowed us to be put
a flexible zoning
plan in place that allowed us to I
believe to look at each individual
project and make it take a more holistic
View
and and act on it so I don't think
there's anything more than that
certainly it's been a focus of the city
to encourage entrepreneurs and investors
to come to our community and make these
types of Investments and it's been a
mission of mine to make sure that the
process is transparent but it's also
somewhat streamlined so we don't
dissuade people from saying geez I don't
want to go to that Community because
you'll be caught in red tape for a
decade that's one of the worst things
that we can do in a community that's so
desperate to have some economic growth
and some more housing stocks so really
that's a focus of myself as well as the
the whole city council I hope that
answers your question
commitment
about the remediation of I'm sure
there's lead paint and Asbestos and
whatever you've found in the groundwater
my concern is that the state taxpayers
end up
um
with a tremendous Bill and I'm wondering
if the commission has any estimates yet
from anyone as to what those costs might
be
thank you very much for the question
representative Thompson
I am not familiar with a really
Dependable estimate that I could share
with you what I can share is years ago
we were fearful that the contamination
level was going to be significant
what we have realized through a phase
two ground
soil study and some building studies is
that based on the commission's work it's
not nearly as extensive as we had feared
and is um
it probably won't be as costly as we
anticipated I know that's still sort of
ambiguous and vague but there was a
sense of relief about from the
commission once that phase two study was
completed that we weren't going to be in
you know where there was some concern
that we might be completely dependent on
Brownfield funding from the federal
government in order to remediate the
property I think right now that
um we feel like we're in a much better
position but I can't go too much deeper
into that because I don't I haven't read
the phase two study and I've only
listened to the commission on that I
hope that's helpful and answer your
question it is thank you very much
uh any further questions from members of
the committee
uh mayor I thank you very much for
clarifying where the city falls down on
the whole process I've been here since
2000 and uh
I did have heard it all from from that
time on and as you know it's been an
ongoing
situation but if you think that the
um
city is in a position to work with Das
and the executive Council and the
governor at this point it is
we we feel the same way you know
legislation takes twists and turns and
you just try to make the best of where
you're at and you know thankfully we
live in a state where we still have good
collaborative relationships with uh in
so many departments so I appreciate that
I also appreciate the work and the
thoughtful
um work you're doing on this bill in
particular thank you
thank you
I have no further pink cards as anybody
who is not testified in favor or against
uh how it's Bill 1032 wish to speak at
this time that anybody who spoke the uh
once we should speak again see now that
I close the public hearing on House Bill
1032.
for the
members of the committee
um you all have and it was sent out by
email as well a um
some research that our committee
researcher did on the legislative
history of the lucodius uh uh Lakes
Region facility it's already back at 99
mid 90s up through the current House
Bill too I also did up a one-pager that
shows what the governor submitted
in-house Bill to what the house passed
and house bill to and what was in the
final version of House Bill 2 of this of
2021. that's just for your edification
to know what the bouncing ball did
through the legislative process and and
both of those documents are are
important for us to consider when we
take up the executive
session on House Bill 1032 which will
not be today so I thank you all and as I
said to the mayor I thought there'd be a
few more people from the city
um here to talk about this so I had
scheduled an hour
we have until 10 30 when we take up a
second bill on the Lakes Region facility
excuse me 10 15.
if you are going to be testifying on
um House Bill 1548 I would appreciate it
if you would fill out a pink card and
I would like to call the public hearing
on House Bill 1548 an act relating to
the sale of the Lakes Region facility to
order and I recognize the prime sponsor
representative fellows welcome
thank you
thank you Mr chair and committee members
I'm representative Sally fellows from
holdiness my district also includes
Plymouth and Hebron
the Budget Trailer bill that we passed
in June included a new RSA that gave the
governor and Council sole authority to
sell the Lakes Region facility in
Laconia
it also amended the definition of Lakes
Region facility
to specifically exclude Ahern park and
if you look on the back side of um
the written testimony that I gave you
you can see
the whole section that was included in
hb2
due to covid
this section of hb2 never received a
public hearing had there been a hearing
I'm certain that the lot that includes
the state 911 call center and Lakes
Region Mutual Aid
um
where the lot where those are located
would have been excluded also there are
people here today who will explain to
you why these unique there are unique
characteristics of this lot that make it
a valuable asset
for the two Public Safety operations
how relocating them
and also how relocating them would be
very costly
so I will just share with you a few
administrative facts the address
um 50 through 67 communication Drive can
be easily excluded because it's included
on the Laconia tax maps it's a 17 acre
parcel it includes the building with the
call center and the Lakes Region Mutual
Aid facility
there's a second building that the state
used last year for covid quarantine and
the parcel also includes part of the
access road to Ahern Park
I checked the status of the RFP for a
retail agent to handle the sale of that
property governor and Council tabled
that item in October
since then it has not appeared on the
calendar
I ask that you passed this bill so any
sale whether it's a sale this year or 10
years from now will not inadvertently
exclude these particular properties
so people who are going to testify
on the specific use of this property can
answer detailed questions about that but
if you have any questions for me I'm
um thank you very much
um
yes thank you excuse me I just want to
make sure here I am where is she
here
did in in the last sentence that you
said I thought I heard you say exclude
and and this says include I just want to
you need to have your
but
so either those property properties
should be excluded
which is the same as not included so
thank you any further questions from
members of the committee
seeing none I would call one of the
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record Bob Guida
Senate District 2 representing 27 towns
in Three Counties Grafton Belknap and
Merrimack a good number of my towns use
the Dispatch Center up there so I'm
speaking in support of this bill for a
number of reasons one we've invested a
significant amount of funding in one
part of the building
and to just
throw that away
wouldn't make a lot of fiscal sense as
well the potential disruption to the
safety structure the infrastructure with
a potential move I have spoken with both
the head of the um
The Dispatch Center and with Bob Quinn's
commissioner Quinn about this they are
looking at another piece of property
and and the caveat of this is that the
concerns I've heard from virtually every
single one of the towns representing uh
that are served by this Dispatch Center
is that many of these towns are on a
shoestring budget they cannot abide an
increase in the fees and costs whether
it's a one-time assessment for building
a new facility or moving the existing
equipment or whether it's an increase
long-term in the usage fees that these
towns pay for using that service
and so my my caveat would be I totally
support the carve out for this
the exception to that would be if any
future move or new building
produced not a penny of increased costs
to the many small towns and communities
uh fire and safety folks that that I
represent and I'll take any questions
thank you Senator questions from the
committee
good morning Senator
um
is there a downstream
to the to the life of these buildings do
we know how long those buildings will
I can't speak with a great deal of
authority but having spoken with
commissioner Quinn and with the uh with
the director of The Dispatch Center
um one part of the building that's used
uh one part of the building is like 50
or 60 years old
and it needs significant help all right
the other part has had upgrades put into
it
um and so
Downstream usage would require uh most
likely a significant renovation of the
part that's still old
um and so that's a possibility I know
that department of safety has is looked
at a a piece of property not too far
away but the costs of moving and then
moving the equipment that we've put in
for the Dispatch Center in the last few
years and that transition would be quite
costly as well so Downstream usage I
have heard from the director of The
Dispatch Center that
they would be willing to take the whole
building but it would require a revamp
and potential lease out of the other
part that that is currently going to
need renovation supposedly now again
that's in my conversations I'm presuming
that he's here and will probably be much
more capable of testifying to those
issues
follow-up
I understand that there's a third
building there that was used for covid
relief
um I wonder if you have any information
on that is that still viable for that
same purpose yeah I have no information
on that okay thank you very much
any further questions from Members
representative McConkey
Senator uh thank thank you for being
here
um the first if I remember correctly uh
representative fellows had mentioned
that this is part of a 17-acre parcel or
shown on an old tax card is 17 acre
parcel and I'm not familiar where this
is on that property having driven by is
there a possibility if we were to keep
one building two building or three
buildings that those those buildings are
up closer to the roadway I'm assuming so
that part of we wouldn't have to
withhold 17 acres for that purpose
and perhaps you're not the right person
probably not the right there's a there's
a there's a meaning when your mic won't
any further questions from members of
the committee
I Nick like to call forward uh John
Goldman
um who has
good morning and thank you for taking
the time to let me speak with you today
my name is John Goldman I'm the chief of
the Lakes Region Mutual fire Aid
District LMR lrmfa is a municipal
Corporation under New Hampshire rsas and
is recognized as a fire Mutual Aid
District by the State Fire Marshal I
represent 35 communities in their fire
and EMS departments in The Lakes region
in central New Hampshire
as well as 110 000 citizens and
taxpayers along with an unimaginable
number of visitors tourists and summer
residents in the state's most heavily
recreated region
the Lakes region in central New
Hampshire is flooded with tourists and
visitors in each of the four seasons
although top quality emergency
communications based on National
knew that was going to happen
uh and standards and best practices are
the major part of what lrmfa does
we also coordinate all the mutual Aid
within the district we offer field
Operations Division a Training Division
which delivers high quality training to
firefighters in the district all over
the state and from as far away as Maine
and Long Island
we're also one of three primary dispatch
centers that manage the State Fire
Marshals Statewide all Hazard
mobilization plan
lrmfa was established in the 50s and
began dispatching from the Laconia fire
station in the 70s in 1980 lmfa moved to
its operations to the courthouse in
Laconia
and then in 2000 they were offered the
opportunity to occupy half of a building
on the state school property since that
time we've occupied our half of the
building on the campus
the other half of the building is
occupied by the New Hampshire division
of emergency communications and houses
the Laconia 911 peace app and other
functions of the Department of Safety
when lrmfa occupied the building we
spent over a million dollars
refurbishing the building and making it
our half of the building making it what
it is today we've maintained our portion
of the building throughout including
HVAC maintenance and any other needs all
the building Although our side of the
building is in reasonable shape there
are maintenance issues which are
expected from a 60 year old building
by being co-located with 9-1-1 both
agencies have realized tremendous
synergies by being next door to each
other for instance the entire building
floats on a battery backup system which
takes over until the generator comes
online in times of power loss
desc built and maintains that system
on the other hand lrmfa built and
maintains a large Communications radio
tower which desc is able to occupy space
on thus saving both agencies from
building redundant systems for the same
building
there's so many benefits to both
agencies being low co-located that I
could go on and on when legislation
passed allowing the governor and Council
to dispose of the state school property
and the RFP was published it took us by
surprise and we were nervous as we had
never thought about or planned for a
relocation
it was never on our radar that this
worst case scenario was a possibility
we began to have conversations with
Department of Safety and our legislators
you can imagine the proposed cost to
build a state-of-the-art Communication
Center from the ground up
aside from losing the Synergy and
benefits to both agencies that have
realized today if lrmfa were to need to
relocate and build a new center these
significant costs would be pushed
directly onto our 35-member communities
and their taxpayers and it may very well
Mark The End Of The District
that would create a vacuum whereas the
29 000 emergency fire and medical calls
that we currently dispatch each year
would need to be pushed on to other
dispatch centers senders centers less
experienced than the nuances of fire and
EMS dispatching and centers not trained
nearly to the level of our professional
certified fire and EMS dispatchers
since the RFP was published we've had
many conversations with the New
Hampshire Department of Safety and are
exploring opportunities to continue to
co-locate with them in a new building
since August we've had much discussion
with safety solidifying our partnership
with them and we look forward to the
opportunity to build the state of the
art peace up and emergency Communication
Center from the ground up
this new opportunity for both agencies
to build a new building would allow both
agencies to continue to be leaders in
the state of New Hampshire and to
provide our residents and visitors with
the best 911 call handling and firing
EMS dispatching possible while
continuing the wonderful relationship
that both agencies have enjoyed for 20
years we look forward to continuing
those discussions with desc and the
Department of Safety
in closing lrmfa has always remained
apolitical over the years and although
we do not want to take a position on
this bill our general position on this
matter as a whole hasn't changed since
day one that position has always been
and continues to be we don't want to
move but we recognize we may not have a
choice and if we do not have that choice
the move cannot cost our communities and
their taxpayers a dime we continue to
Advocate if we're asked to relocate that
the full cost of relocation must not be
born Upon Our member communities and we
look forward to the opportunity to
continue to work with safety and DSC to
make that a reality thank you for your
time and I'm happy to answer any
questions that you may have
um thank you one request that I have I
noticed that you are reading your
testimony if you could leave that for
the clerk for the for the file it makes
it much easier on the the minutes
um
that's good
it's it still beats his handwriting
but
um one question that I have before I
look around to the to the committee is
you talk that you were in discussions
with the other agencies about building a
new facility
during these discussions are you looking
at the same location or different
I would probably defer most of that to
director Doyle
um we we have located a piece of
property that I think would be
beneficial uh to both agencies uh and
and realistically you know as I said
it's a 60 year old building although we
don't want to take a position on the
bill six-year-old building is certainly
to to your point to the end of you know
getting close to the end of its its life
cycle
thank you any questions from members of
the committee representative
thank you Mr chairman
um so according to this bill that we
have before us they want to take a 17
acre parcel of land you guys don't need
the entire parcel that we're currently
so little history many years ago a few I
don't know 10 years ago or so maybe a
little bit more the entire parcel was
one parcel at some point the state
presumably carved off the 17 Acres that
we sit on which is our building which
911 co-locates in as well as that
building that's used for the covid
um covet lodging and I think the the
intent we believed at the time the
intent was now that that's carved off
it's removed from we don't have anything
to worry about so to speak but
um
I can't answer whether we would need 17
Acres follow-up
just a follow-up so if we were able to
find a designated space that you're
actually occupying and when your Tower
is located and carve that out
individually that would work as well
correct
I would have to check with my with my
executive committee I don't have the
ability to speak specifically to that
any representative Eaton
hi Chief I'm a director of Southwest
Mutual Aid um
you made a statement that if anything
occurs not one penny should go on the
Lakes Region
it the state builds a new facility are
you or is the association
intending to pay part of the cost of
that or are you expecting to get rent
free and moving free
so we currently pay rent we also pay our
prorated portion if you will of the
electric bill
um I don't know that
that anybody would be opposed to to uh
reevaluating that lease option right and
what those ongoing expenses might be
we've had discussions with safety and
desc at this point
um
we would like to co-locate with them at
their new building if that's the
direction that they go and I think
that's the best option for for everybody
realistically if there's a new building
you start all the way over you know and
you build from the ground up state of
the art it's really difficult to manage
a six-year-old building and continue to
maintain it as a state-of-the-art
facility which it is today for us
follow-up
I assume you're aware Southwest we
purchased the Old Keene fire department
which is 150 years old and we have a
state-of-the-art facility that handles
five times the
the population or communities that you
do and
are doing well and we've floated a bond
to the communities to do that
from an lrmfa perspective we never
when once we located in that building we
didn't necessarily have on our radar
that we were going to move so we weren't
we were not and are not prepared for
that to float a bond that certainly is
an option but the concern for us is it's
never been talked about so if we were to
just start doing that now one of our
concerns is if one of our communities
were to to withdraw
that pushes their costs onto the other
communities and then it continues to
Domino from there Southwest has done a
fantastic job with that building
um that job that they did with that
building is basically what we did 20
years ago when we when we moved into the
building so we would almost have to redo
any further questions from members of
I like to call forward I'm Miss Mark
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for giving me an
opportunity to speak with you this
morning regarding HB 1548 we heard a lot
from our partners at Lakes Region
director Goldman and his team have
worked very closely with the Department
of Safety and my folks to look at what
the potential is for potential impacts
are going to be and the potential for
scalability is when we end up
giving the notice that we have to move
off that property in the event that it
sold so a lot of work as you had heard
from director Goldman has gone into the
planning and potential execution of a
move and what that entails so we've done
a lot of homework to this point a lot
still lies ahead we've looked at it from
where we are right now you've heard a
little bit about it being a 60 year old
building and some of the inherent
problems that go along with that just to
give you a frame of reference and the
last
12 to 18 months we've replaced HVAC
systems boiler systems over the last few
years we've replaced the roof on that
building
we anticipate that the costs associated
with the upkeep and maintenance are
going to continue as would any 60 year
old building we had not anticipated on
moving anytime soon but further notice
that this is a potential that that we
will put on alert for back in early
summer having said that we are taking a
look at the opportunities that exist
that that do present themselves in the
event that we have to move including a
state-of-the-art emergency
communications center renew 9-1-1 psap
and as the Director of New Hampshire
9-1-1 it's my responsibility to make
sure that only the highest level in
quality of service is rendered to the
folks who rely on 9-1-1 Services
throughout the state and for those folks
that visit the state the reason we have
the secondary psap and I call it a
secondary pcap only because there are
two it really isn't secondary it's a
primary by virtue of the the design that
it's built on
is because we have redundancy built into
place the redundancy exists with that
9-1-1 Center the redundancy that is in
that building as well as far as the
radio communication system for state
police also exists in that Center as
well
so there were a number of other
contingencies that play into our
decision and play into the consideration
and planning associated with any move
when we talk about a move we've also
talked about where is this going to be
and as you heard Chief Goldman speak to
we've taken a look at some potential
properties in and around the area one of
which we thought because our goal is to
co-locate with our partners at Lake's
region is to make sure that that move is
in that Lakes Region Mutual fire rate
District
interestingly enough the location that
we've actually put eyes on and have had
to start a discussion with is a
state-owned property that's currently
leased to the City of Laconia that's
about three quarters of a mile away from
where we currently sit
so from a purpose or perspective of
making a move and reduction in costs to
move equipment that certainly is an
efficiency that we can realize we also
wanted to make sure that our emergency
Communication System that's currently up
and running right now that supports
State Police and other Public Safety
stakeholders around the state goes with
us and there's not going to be a huge
lift
cost wise associated with that as well
because we're moving just a very short
distance away we still have line of
sight with our radio communications
towers that handle and provide backhaul
for that communication system
the costs associated with that move that
we started to explore right now a very
very rudimentary and and we're not
holding any Credence in other than to
give us a frame of reference again as to
what that might
might cost as far as building a new
emergency Communication Center and a new
psap with the space studies that we've
done for the 911 side of the house as
well as for Lakes Region and it can be
anywhere from seven to ten million
dollars plus or minus
that doesn't include the costs
associated with having to build new
systems if that's something that has to
be done right now it doesn't look like
that it has to be done because many of
the systems that we have in place right
now including the data operations center
the 911 called delivery Network and the
radio communications system that we have
in place for state police that acts as a
redundant backup are fairly new they
would not have to be actually purchased
and rebuilt and bought just moved simply
speaking it's not as easy putting all
that equipment in the back of a pickup
truck and driving it up the street and
then unloading it and then plugging it
back in I'm not an I.T guy I know a
little about the IT world so there's
going to be a lot of work in the
planning and project development as far
as not only the construction of the
building and whatnot but also the
implementation of putting those systems
back in place we've worked very closely
with our Commissioner's Office we'll
work very closely with the folks over at
Department of administrative Services
Charlene arleyhaus and his team to talk
about what that's going to look good our
next steps are to actually get money put
aside in the 911 side of the house to
start construction design and
Architectural scoping of what it looks
like to put a new facility on that
parcel that we've currently started to
look at right now we want to make sure
that at the very least from a planning
and responsibility perspective that we
have this in our back pocket but what I
want to make sure is is that everybody
here in the committee is aware of the
very close partnership that we form with
our friends at Lakes Region that we've
had in place before this even started to
happen back in the summer and that we've
really solidified over the last eight to
nine months because of what has been
coming down the train track since so far
as the potential move we have been made
very clear
to them and it's been made very clear to
us at the department of safety and the
division emergency services that they
are our partners now and they will be in
any further move to take a look at
opportunities that exist now moving
forward I think is a great opportunity
to say that we can actually put in place
what would be developed built and
designed as emergency communications
center and 9-1-1 Public Safety answering
point that we currently have over at
Smokey Bear Boulevard at the iPod and
that pretty much summarizes exactly what
all I wanted to say was this morning and
to reiterate again friends at Lakes
Region stand very closely with us in
terms of trying to work work out the
minutia and the details associated with
any potential move and what that looks
like and I'm available to answer any
questions that any of you might have
uh any questions from members of the
thank you Mr Dahl for your testimony so
so it appears in the legislation that
came through uh through you folks in a
bit of a quandary what are we going to
do if we have to move
and you've started down that road and it
sounds extremely expensive for my seat
sitting here so let's let's talk about
the the building you're in
and I share is there is there adequate
room for growth in the building you're
in I'm not talking about roof and
structure is there adequate room to do
what it is you need to do there
which is where I believe I'm sorry where
I believe you thought you were going to
be two years ago
thank you for your question
representative McConkey that's actually
a very good question and I I can't
recall who the representative was that
asked the question of director Goldman
before about the building that's
situated on the same parcel there it's
called The Doobie building it's vacant
right now but it was used for
covert overflow for folks that needed a
place to stay during the covid response
that building was looked at several
years ago by not only our department of
safety and our division as an expansion
point to move over because of the lack
of growth in the current building we're
all sitting on roughly
I think about eleven thousand twelve
thousand square footage of space which
includes our Public Safety answering
Point as well as our database mapping
and I T departments that work in that
same building
Lakes region is a little bit less than
that but we had been looking at other
opportunities to expand we can't go up
on that building because of the nature
of the design and it is 60 years old so
whenever you start to try to build onto
or adjacent to you actually try to think
about whether this is not going to be a
cost-effective move or not one of the
things that we did look at was that
building across the parking lot which is
the Doobie building what doesn't right
now present itself as an adequate
location because of all the necessary
upgrades and improvements that would
have to be done which would include
improvements to the infrastructure to
make building hold compliant for what it
is that we wanted to put in there right
now right now we haven't looked at any
other opportunities to
expand but the opportunities to expand
inside that physical structure right now
are limited in almost a non-existent
you'd mentioned making improvements to
the HVAC system and so forth are those
recent and was was someone able to
access our funds for that purpose
thank you for your question
representative McConkey and the answer
to that is they they were recent
uh in so far as being as recent as over
the last month our data center air
conditioning system failed completely
and we actually had to put in fans to
draw air out of there for the time being
until which time we could get a vendor
up to work on replacing those systems
and they are fairly expensive as you can
imagine the other system that we had to
have replaced and is being worked on
right now is our boiler system which I
believe I don't want to speak other than
my belief right now is that it's about a
60 year old system that came with the
building that's
being plugged Along on life support as
many of those systems currently are but
it's being worked on as we speak right
now there are pumps associated with
pushing the diesel fuel through the
system to allow for the heating to work
and those systems are
being replaced
follow-up
thank you Mr chairman one one easy one
for you uh the street address of your
building so I can see it online here
certainly and thank you for that our
actual address for the psap is 550
Communications Drive
thank you sir
I do have one question following on what
representative McConkey just
alluded to the arpa funds and now the
new infrastructure funds that are
available has the department
held any discussions with uh
the fiscal committee the governor or
anybody about
can any of those funds be used for this
building move if it's necessary
thank you for your question Mr chairman
I I can't answer that directly I know
it's been discussed at my level with the
commissioner I'm not aware whether the
commissioner has had any more into the
weeds or detailed discussion about
potential Opera funding for any move
if you could
look into that a little bit more and
provide some information to the
committee on the availability of the
funds so that when we discuss this and
whether or not we we go along with it at
least we have some background of if it's
going to cost you 10 million dollars
could the 10 million dollars be out
there somewhere
understood and I can certainly do that
any other questions representative
Thompson
um
I'm a money guy
it's it's all about the money it always
is
um what do you anticipate and you must
have
in your meetings anticipated the costs
of building a building and relocating
all this what does that boil down to and
I don't need it in specific terms but
are we talking 10 million 25 million
right now thank you for your question
representative Thompson but right now
some of the initial numbers that we've
obtained and again it's
40 000 foot level are anywhere between
seven and ten million dollars for
facility of the size that we've already
put some study into as well as for the
move of any equipment that we currently
have in place not building of new
systems
thank you
any other questions from members of the
committee
uh if not thank you very much and I
would appreciate that that information
about
and the availability of funds whether or
not you get them but whether you can't
even apply for them
thank you and I'll make sure I forward
there being no further
um pink cards up here has anybody who
has not testified on the house bill
1548 uh wish to speak at this time it's
anybody who has spoken once we should
speak again say none I will close the
public hearing on House Bill 1548.
our next hearing is at 11 A.M it is
House Bill 1432 and I do not expect a
whole lot of people but it
take a deep breath get a cup of coffee I
think that there will be quite a few
people in here to talk about that bill
I would ask that anybody that is here to
testify on House Bill 1432 please please
fill out a pink card so that we can
organize how people are going to be
not everyone
once again a reminder for anybody who is
planning on testifying and in favor or
against House Bill 1432 I do need a pink
card uh without a pink card you will not
get called to the witness stand thank
the time being 11 A.M I would call the
public hearing on House Bill 1432 and
act prohibiting the use of State funds
for new passenger rail projects to order
and recognize the prime sponsor
representative
ankenberg and I probably messed up that
if I did correct me
if it's ready to talk there we go good
morning Mr chairman and the committee
I'm here to
present for the record I'm Aidan
Ankerberg I represent Stratford District
10. the lovely city of Rochester
I'm here to present uh House Bill 1432
this is a very simple bill it prevents
State funding from being used to
subsidize new commuter rail projects
the intent of the bill is to protect New
Hampshire taxpayers from this financial
boondoggle
this bill specifically prohibits State
funding from being used to plan
construct operate or manage a new
Commuter Rail Project
of course this deals primarily with the
capital Corridor Rail Project
um in 2014 the Department of
Transportation presented the last
financial plan for this project
of course we are approaching a new phase
of this where the financial plan for
this current iteration of it will be
introduced sometime later this year
early next year
um
so back in 2014 they estimated that New
Hampshire taxpayers would be on the hook
for 10.8 million dollars annually and
that was in 2012 dollars
with
246 and a half million dollars in
additional Capital costs for the
infrastructure
fast forward to today the department
cannot give concrete figures of the
total expenditure costs or annual annual
operating expenses
estimates say that adjusted for
inflation alone the current projections
leave us at a conservative figure of
292.7 million dollars in capital
expenditures and 12.8 million dollars in
annual operating expenses I have a I
have a chart
I have a pie chart over there that shows
in
2016 in terms of federal projects that
were presented for funding
um that the overwhelming number of those
projects were proposed to be funded
through sales taxes both local state
um and an additional taxing mechanisms
um so with the the costs Rising on this
project
and inflation at his 40-year historic
highs projected ridership also to be
lower given the pandemic and other
factors there really is in my opinion no
need for for this and the capital
Corridor project seems to be a solution
in desperate need of a problem so that
would conclude my testimony
thank you questions from members of the
committee
for everybody who is here once again if
you're planning on speaking I do need a
pink card they're back there you can
fill it out and pass it up for everybody
who is watching live streamed and have
sent in emails uh remote testimony and
the rest all of that will be
incorporated into the public record I am
not going to read all of them there
there are multiple but rest assured we
have got them and we have been reading
them both pro and con so I thank
everybody on the public who has done
that and with that I will go to one of
the other sponsors uh representative
Leon
there you go thank you Mr chair and
thank you members for the committee and
thank you for that
my name is Erica Leon I represent
Rockingham six which is dairy uh I am a
sponsor on this because I have a degree
in economics and I used to be a Bart
commuter into San Francisco when I
worked on the trading floor and then I
used to be a bus commuter into Boston I
used to take the bus down and I'd only
do it when it was the local because they
were able to drop me off in my office
which saved me a 15-minute walk
otherwise it made more sense for me to
drive in I also got to enjoy the double
taxation when I drove in walking past
the Tea Party site enjoying paying
income tax to Massachusetts and paying
my property taxes here in New Hampshire
while this may be a benefit for some of
our commuters we have an issue of a lot
of our businesses moving out of downtown
Boston and out of other concentrated
areas to build their own campuses
throughout Massachusetts so it's a lot
more diffuse it's a lot harder to
deliver the employees to their
workplaces and then if we and end up
funding this through increased property
taxes sales taxes or another increase we
are going to lose the advantage for
these people who find their home here in
New Hampshire yet continue to work in
Massachusetts if they're taxed on their
income in Massachusetts and then they
have an additional tax burden here in
New Hampshire they will be less likely
to live here and they'll be more likely
to move into Mass back to Massachusetts
or down there in order to improve their
overall taxation while I appreciate the
idea of having a train to deliver you in
comfort and peace to work which I
actually could do on BART surprisingly
enough it's something where as it
increases if we have it it might
actually end up being a solution that
has even fewer Riders when they look at
their pocketbook and see what happens
with the taxes I'd love to have this if
the money grew on trees but I I don't
think that it is a prudent use of our
taxpayers resources and I don't see a
clear path to providing it without
creating more economic harm for our
citizens are already highly stressed
financially
thank you
thank you questions from members of the
committee
representative Michael O'Brien in
thank you Mr chairman uh let me
introduce myself I'm representative
Michael O'Brien I've represent District
26 which is the ward 9 the city of
Nashua
I also am vice president of nashua's
board of alderman I give you greetings
from the mayor of Nashua and I speak on
his behalf of support I mean against
this particular Bill and support of
commuter rail
we often hear in these Hollow Chambers
it should not be the objective of one
legislative body to handcuff future
legislative bodies
and if we take that basic premise that
is exactly what this bill does
it removes from the table
any future discussion on commuter rail
I recommend on that alone that your itl
this bill
now if you were an investor
and you saw that the state of New
Hampshire
didn't like your particular business
would you invest in New Hampshire
now
one party over the other party some say
better for business
let's all act together for what is good
for business
now let's look at the city of Nashua
nashua's history is the gate City
Manchester to Queen City but how did
Nashua become to Gate City
because we were the Gateway via the
railroad
we are the ones that opened up the door
to New Hampshire we still do
yet Nashua Bears great burdens
from the state do you know how much per
capita the lottery relies on the city of
Nashua and Manchester the largest cities
many towns that perhaps where you come
from do not have Keno
yet Nashua sells Kino and supplies
heavily
to the education within Nashua Nash was
ready to develop
you better add a couple more seats over
across the way there because going by
the last census nashua's population has
increased
and the people in Nashua want to commute
a rail who are we
as a legislative body
want to say that somebody cannot earn
Boston wages
yet live in New Hampshire
if we vote for this particular bill in
essence that's what we're saying
people who take away the opportunity for
people to go down within the Boston
Market
and earn the Boston wage and bring the
money back into New Hampshire makes good
economic sense to me
and I'm not an economist I'm a
firefighter I was a firefighter but it
makes good economic sense to me
that uh subsidies people you've got to
hear that
well that's a kind of a weak argument
we subsidize every form of
transportation in this state except for
commuter rail
we subsidize the Manchester Airport
national airport we subsidize buses I've
had a good fortune in the past working
with one of the representatives on this
board up in his community of uh buses
for that particular town
and it comes with some subsidies from
the state
if we in Nashua and I just want to say
too
in Nashua this is not a Johnny come
lately decision
I am on the mayor's task force for
commuter rail I've been on it for eight
years we've been working hard on this
those are the you know me
also note I was former acting chair and
vice chair for years in the
transportation department next door we
have worked hard on this particular
issue but if I ever saw anybody coming
up with the final nail of the coffin
this is the bill that could do it
now I heard some numbers those aren't
raw card numbers
because I'm on those committees do you
think I would have seen them
nobody really knows where this is going
to really end up but it's a concept that
still needs to be vetted and to disgust
and to put it to bed now will never
allow that's the state and the people of
my community
to get to see now the commuter Realm
is there a need for it
you're in the position of highways
as you know in Massachusetts
basically in Nashua roof Reese topped
off
if I came out and told you right now
let's wider them and put another Lane in
we can't
imminent domain
you'll be encroaching on private
property
we're there
now over across the backboard in the
past
we heard other ideas of flying cars
I supported that technology
by representative Smith
but here's a problem
what do you do with a flying car when
you get to Boston
do you have to stack them
and that's what commuter rail will
eliminate it's always been the answer
mass transportation is the answer
it will allow the lake again the people
to go down and work within the Boston
Market
now
how does that affect the people up in
remote New Hampshire who probably won't
see that commuter rail
it sure does
because the state of New Hampshire sets
the tax rate for the city of Nashua
and if this is a success to which I
firmly believe and hope you share my
enthusiasm that it is
that tax rate will be uncovered will be
assessed to the city and come back in
tax dollars
to this state
Nashville just is looking
for the opportunity
to do its job by a careful form of
government of trying to make it grow and
be a total supplier
or supporter for some of the funding in
the state
we have a lot of things in Nashua
we have
Workforce housing
we have veterans homes for people who
cannot have have difficulties
transitioning a lot of things that have
come from other communities end up in
the city
Nashua has broad shoulders and we can
handle it but we need something
economically to continue to make us grow
not to be depending upon the state but
to be a leader
economically
this is a pro business bill
and if you look and if people did their
homework in the town of Hudson
they're opening the Amazon
distribution center
what they'd not like to have Amazon
if you have commuter rail you have
Freight
would Amazon like to have Freight
good question this would kill it
so I therefore I really would re ask
nicely to put your thinking caps on
forget any partisan politics or anything
else but look at the facts that this is
something that needs to be further
discussed and vetted
to come back and looking at the future
for that's what we're supposed to be
doing as elective Representatives
and look at the future what commuter
rail can do and as far again with the
subsidies
we subsidize the roads we pave them we
scrape them the snow salt them
this is no different
no different at all
and as a matter of fact with covid
the MBTA has seen a 54 percent increase
back from covet
so this is something that's got to go in
the future people of the state want a
transportation alternative please
allowed them to have that moment and I
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
representative any questions from
members of the committee saying none
next day I would call forward
representative foam in support of the
bill
and those coming up to testify
please try not to repeat what's already
been said and keep
present us with new facts if at all
thank you Mr chairman all of members of
Public Works I am Ralph Baum
Hillsborough District 20 town of
Litchfield
in the early 90s I was on Judd Gregg's
Railway commission we studied bringing
commuter rail to Nashua we had many
meetings and included representatives
from the MBTA after a year discussing
and looking at the issues it was
determined that computer rail was not
feasible
and even more so now
it would determine that the tracks from
Lowell up would have to be completely
replaced and include turn off tracks the
existing track is 15 Mile hour Freight
that's track speed not train speed
and worse now has there's less train
traffic and is not suitable for a fast
and as was mentioned earlier about
Freight Freight is is coming up now it
can be
so
of course the initial cost of the trains
we need the upkeep of them or is that
coming from my other pocket the one that
pays federal taxes the MBP MBTA is paid
for by the Massachusetts state sales tax
and property tax from most of the towns
east of 495. towns are assessed even
though no rail may be even go through
the town
this is to pay to subsidy as needed as
needed as passengers do not of rail do
not pay the cost
and referred that the MBTA is still
having financial problems also in the
1990s there was a commuter rail for
Merrimack to Lowell was tried it only
lasted about a year as with very little
usage
the argument that all transportation is
subsidized only goes so far yes our
property taxes we pay for Road plowing
improvements etc
etc but that we can control by our vote
there will be no way to say no to a
state and proposed subsidy tax we all
use the roads a very small amount will
use the rail and why should I pay to
make it cheaper for someone to go to
Massachusetts and why should we make it
easy for New Hampshire residents to work
in Massachusetts and in a pandemic what
better way to transmit it than on a
train
instead of spending money on trains the
money should be spent on New Hampshire
making it more cost effective for
businesses to move to New Hampshire so
their workers don't have to commute
30 years ago there was a push for the
circumferential Highway which was
supposed to alleviate traffic in Nashua
Highway was planned to go through Hudson
and then cross back over to Litchfield
Hudson line one of the main reasons for
the highway was the train traffic and
Nashua would stop traffic for long
periods of time between Hudson and as
went back the train traffic is nil now
had very little Freight and most of that
was coal trains
the circumference no longer needed
traffic is low and trains are less
frequent
some things same thing will happen if
Royale has started with a lot of remote
work there will be less need for the
people working remotely there will be
less need for a train and even now road
traffic is lower and will continue to
decrease and if Nashua and Manchester
want it they can do it we don't have to
pay for everybody's things they want
thank you
thank you do I see any questions from
members of the committee seeing none
thank you representative
next I'd like to call forward
representative love
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
representative David love I represent
Rockingham six which is Derry and uh I'd
ask you to turn around and take a look
at that map behind you and and draw an
inch and a half circle around Manchester
and Nashville because those are the
people that will be going to be greatly
benefited by uh the rail service the
rest of the state won't uh you know I I
drive a limo you know and uh from the
Derry area I I make Logan Airport in a
45 to 50 minutes
um and if I went from Derry to
Manchester waited to get on a train uh
we're talking more time than that plus
more money okay
um you know it isn't fair to burden the
rest of the state with with projects for
um for Manchester and Nashua you know
it's it's very unfair and um you know
I'd ask you to to vote this OTP
um you know just on that basis alone if
a business can't stand on its own
without subsidies that shouldn't be
business you know
um you know we've we've got to stop
doing this uh the the tax rates that
people are always complaining about the
the tax rates and how much they pay in
property taxes uh we'll be adding more
taxes uh God only knows what they'll tax
next and uh we can't afford it you know
it's um you know and then once again it
just isn't right to ask the people of
Rochester or Romney a hand over to be
subsidizing this
that's it thanks
uh thank you for your testimony are
there any questions from members of the
committee saying none thank you
uh Mr Greg Moore representing Americans
in support of the bill
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee appreciate the opportunity to
testify here today uh in favor of house
bill 1432. I actually had a chance to
talk to my old boss former speaker
O'Brien who is now a Nashua resident who
said to me we should have thought about
this 10 years ago so first of all I'd
like to thank the sponsor for for doing
something that we probably should have
done 10 years ago
uh House Bill 1432 is is important in
the sense that it says that the state
will not subsidize any new commuter rail
service it does not say that new
commuter Royal Service cannot happen it
does not say that that other sources of
funding can't be used to fund commuter
rail if the city of Nashua thinks it's a
great idea the city of Nashua can has is
not blocked by this legislation in terms
of in terms of bringing commuter rail in
Nashua so I I want to make abundantly
clear this is this legislation in no way
shape or form blocks any new commuter
rail Services all it says is that the
state citizen shouldn't subsidize it and
it's it is a benefit that would that
would benefit a very very small number
of New Hampshire residents whereas
attacks in order to pay for it would
impact all New Hampshire residents so we
think that this is a the this
legislation is a good idea we think that
ensuring that uh the state state
taxpayers are protected from it but I
think the important question is is from
a net net perspective what this bill
does
as an earlier uh an earlier
speaker said one legislature cannot buy
in the hands of a future legislature and
what this bill would do should it become
law this legislation would ensure that
Department of Transportation and other
organizations could not go running wild
coming up with a plan for for a new
commuter rail it means that they would
know that any plan for commuter rail
that involved any state subsidies would
have to come back through this Committee
in order to become law so this this
means that that any plans any plans for
future commuter rail Pros project would
have to would have to be brought forward
to this committee if they're going to
use State dollars so this committee
would gains more control about any
future Commuter Rail Products by passage
of house bill 1432. I think that's an
important thing to consider going
forward as well so with that I'd be
happy to take any questions
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions from members of the
uh Mr E.J Powers representing New
Hampshire businesses for rail expansion
can you hear me now thanks
chairman Graham and members of the
committee my name is EJ powers and I'm
with New Hampshire businesses for rail
expansion
it's not often when you find an
initiative that has a support of 75
percent of New Hampshire residents it's
rare when that support comes from
majority of residents from every
political party every gender every age
every education level every ideology and
in every County of the state
it's even more rare when businesses both
large and small
from coffee shops to construction
companies and Banks to biotech startups
led by the staunchest Republicans in the
leftist-leaning Liberals
all agree to support a specific project
well that initiative is the expansion of
Passenger rail from Boston to Nashua and
Manchester and those supporters are your
neighbors your friends your family
members and your constituents
they support this initiative because of
the overwhelming Economic Development
benefits that it would provide which
would supercharge New Hampshire's
already booming economy and bring 5600
permanent jobs 3 400 construction jobs
Seventeen hundred new jobs every year
after 2030. 3 600 residential units and
we all know we have a housing shortage
here in New Hampshire 9 million square
feet of commercial space
750 million dollars in real estate
investment and 220 million dollars in
reinvested worker earnings added to the
economy
rail expansion has also received
wide-ranging bipartisan support
in August 2018 governor sununu and the
governor's advisory Commission on
Intermodal Transportation included
Federal funding for Intermodal excuse me
included Federal funding for the project
development phase in the state's 10-year
Transportation Improvement plan
rail expansion was even touted in the
state's response to the Amazon h2q
proposal
currently the project development phase
is underway and that is examining
multiple aspects of the proposed Capital
Corridor expansion Expansion Project
this is an in-depth analysis which is
providing solid environmental
engineering and financial data to give
you our trusted Representatives
all the information you need to make an
informed decision as to whether or not
passenger rail should be expanded with
two stops in Nashua in a stop in
Manchester and at the Manchester Boston
Regional Airport
as written HB 1432 would eliminate all
prospects for investing in rail it would
thwart the will of the overwhelming
majority of New Hampshire residents and
would squander this potential Economic
Development opportunity
it's an unnecessary preemptive bill
simply
the fat you we don't have all the facts
right now to make an educated decision
and it presumes the state should invest
zero dollars in an infrastructure
project before the data is in Veil is
available to you
so I urge you on behalf of 75.5 percent
of New Hampshire residents
and 110 plus bipartisan Statewide
businesses that I represent to reject HB
1432.
thank you
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions from members of the
committee
I don't know okay everybody hear me now
all right a question Mr Powers you
talked about the business committee's
support uh support for Rail and I was
wondering if you've talked to your
members and speaking to the members of
your organization are they willing to to
help Pony up to help pay for this
especially the capital cost and maybe
the operating costs maybe voluntarily on
their own uh to help get this started
and help reduce the tax burden if
thank you for the question uh there's
been strong business support dating back
to I think 2006 when the business
Community actually uh ponied up money to
help with some early studies to examine
the feasibility of rail one of the
important things to think about is that
this financial plan that the project
development phase is undertaking is
examining a number of options of funding
and we recognize we're in the state of
New Hampshire we recognize there are
non-starters when it comes to investment
options and public-private Partnerships
can play a significant role in this
project and there are a number of
businesses that stand to benefit and
it's not just through the you know
through the Manchester and Nashua area
yes that is sort of the engine for New
Hampshire's economy when it comes to
economic development but I would liken
the potential Economic Development
opportunities for this project to the
Manchester Boston Regional Airport you
may live in Berlin and never fly out of
that airport but you're still reaping
the billion plus dollars in economic
activity that's derived from that and
this project offers those same
opportunities however if we refuse to
fund it without having any data before
us we do ourselves in future
legislatures and citizens of New
Hampshire to service
all right thank you follow up
okay all right you said pump mentioned
public private Partnerships so are you
sort of saying in favor of a
public-private partnership with your
maybe the businesses you represent and
state government or even public private
Partnerships among all the communities
uh that will be served by the rail line
between Manchester and uh Nashua
I think all options would be on the
table there's a number of businesses and
organizations that stand to benefit as
well as the citizens and
um there are no firm plans for uh the
financing at this point but there is
very strong interest in this from the
business Community okay okay thank you
uh thank you any further questions from
members of the community seeing none
uh Wendy hunt representing the greater
Nashua and Manchester Chambers in
opposition to the bill
and if you could get at least one copy
of your written testimony up to the
clerks so he could uh
good morning thank you for
giving us the opportunity to speak today
chairman Graham and members of the House
Public Works and highways committee my
name is Wendy hunt I'm the president and
CEO of the greater Nashua Chamber of
Commerce I also speak on behalf of my
colleague Mike Skelton president and CEO
of the greater Manchester Chamber of
Commerce who was unable to be here in
person to testify today
I'm here today to emphasize our
continued support of rail expansion in
New Hampshire collectively our
organizations represent more than 1400
businesses across Southern New Hampshire
that employ tens of thousands of our
state's residents and generate millions
in economic activity
the Nashua Manchester Corridor also
serves as the economic backbone of our
entire State as goes the economic output
of our region so goes the rest of New
Hampshire therefore economic growth
along the national Manchester Corridor
is important to the overall growth of
our entire State's economy
the New Hampshire Capital Corridor Rail
Project has the potential to have a
transformative impact on New Hampshire's
economy by positively impacting the
Nashville Manchester corridor
New Hampshire's 2015 Capitol quarter
Rail and Transit story detailed all this
EJ just a few minutes ago gave you all
those figures so they are in my notes I
won't repeat them but they are
significant and what the economic impact
would be of rail
this same study also revealed a host of
additional economic and societal
benefits stemming from rail expansion
including improving access to the entire
region playing a major role in retaining
young people serving as a catalyst for
smart development in creating a
multimodal transportation infrastructure
for the state
fast forward to today and we are
anxiously awaiting the results of a two
and a half year study or also known as a
project development phase of Railway
expansion New Hampshire being conducted
by AECOM Technical Services Incorporated
of Manchester with a price tag of 5.5
5.4 million dollars of taxpayer money
the PDP will not be completed until
January 23rd one year from now
completing this PDP is crucial as it
will allow for a complete understanding
of the costs and benefits of rail
expansion and allow policy makers and
the public to have the facts needed to
consider this important Economic
Opportunity for New Hampshire when
completed the study will lay out the
engineering environmental and financial
plan of rail expansion
it is our position that HP 1432 is
clearly premature it seems more
appropriate for the legislature to wait
until this PDP this 5.4 million dollar
PDP is completed then with all the facts
rail expansion could be openly discussed
and debated at that appropriate time
moreover as written HB 1432 will limit
the ability of future legislators to
provide transportation's options to the
citizens of New Hampshire on behalf of
the 1400 businesses and tens of
thousands of their employees that we
represent we ask this committee to
recommend that HB 1432 be found an
expedient to legislate at this time
now I
as Chambers of Commerce we seek a
pro-business agenda
we don't want to waste a taxpayer monies
either and I know that this is what a
lot of this is about can't we at least
get all of the information before we
rush to this decision so I ask that you
take that into consideration that we all
want the facts and to do so this early
in the game would really shut out the
future potential of rail
thank you for your consideration
thank you uh representative
thank you Mr chair thank you Wendy for
your testimony so all I keep hearing
from everybody who's testified so far is
Manchester National Manchester Nashua I
represent Laconia how is the rail going
to benefit me and my constituents
if you think about the business taxes
that our companies pay in our region
that's why we are the big economic
Powerhouse that spreads throughout the
state those economic things I know from
a chamber standpoint too because I
talked to my my colleagues who read the
state that every
every region the state is having a war
Workforce issue having the rail would
bring a lot of workers into New
Hampshire I know one company right now
has to go down and bus employees up from
Lowell and and
um
I can't remember what the other city is
Lawrence
we need Workforce we are not going to
grow
as an economy without more workers and
covet has made that even worse the other
thing I'm hearing in today's testimony
is about commuters going south to Boston
Regional Airport and the state also
subsidizes the Boston Express as a
taxpayer in New Hampshire that bothers
me
we should be promoting our airport the
Manchester the Boston Manchester
Regional and not leaking all of those
passengers and Dollars South to Logan in
Boston so that Railway runs both ways we
any further questions from members of
the committee seeing none thank you
I have no other pink cards if anybody
who has not testified for or against
House Bill 1432 and would like to speak
please fill out a pink card
at this time
I think representative Cloutier is
probably going to ask for a question of
Dot
I did on another bill tomorrow could you
read the we will get to that
yeah
Bradley if you could send up the uh blue
sheet so you send it up here and I do
have a question of the department if
they would be so kind
for the record uh William cast assistant
the commissioner and with me is Shelly
Winters who's the administrator of the
Bureau of rail and uh Transit
the the real question that I have and I
think a couple of the other members of
the committee have is
the specific language in this bill says
including the projects named Manchester
I mean Nashua Manchester con uh Concord
project number
in the
2019-2028 10-year Transportation
Improvement plan the question that I
have is if this was to pass
are we using any state funds currently
to do that project or the or the uh
study the the study that has been
referenced
no uh the project development phase
that's being worked on now that was
referenced is uh funded with a 100
federal funds so no no State funds are
being currently used
follow up there
thank you so just to clarify uh whether
this bill passes or not the project
development phase contract that's
already been awarded and is in progress
I don't believe so not by strict
interpretation of of the of the of the
wording um certainly it would be our
intent and I believe hopefully the
legislators intent that we finish the uh
project development phase and the
financial plan so that we have all of
representative Faulkner
uh
not that are charging time to the
project are they uh
is that not accounted for separately
is not currently charging any time to
ask you a question that I asked
yesterday
do you know if this project assuming you
know it's it's eligible you know and
meet certain criteria would this project
the capital cost qualify for any of the
money under the bipartisan
infrastructure plan that was passed last
year
uh yes yes it would okay all right thank
you the one the one caveat though that
we've been dealing with through the
study most of the federal funds uh for
the capital costs do come with some sort
of matching requirement matching okay
all right thank you for that
clarification and thank you Mr chairman
thank you any further questions of the
department I just wanted to clarify that
one issue
um thank you for for answering
um representative Clutier asked about
the blue sheet there are 18 people who
had signed up either Pro uh in support
of the bill or against the bill
um it was 17 in favor of the bill and
one um
a post to the bill on the blue sheet as
I said at the start of the hearing there
has been a lot of email that has been
sent to the committee some with uh
testimony attached I know I have read it
all I assume that all of the rest of the
committee has as well and we'll take
that into consideration when we get
around to our uh debate at some future
day on this bill
and all of those will be incorporated
into the official file for uh house bill
1432.
having said that
is there anybody who wishes to speak on
are you going to speak are you going to
you need a paint card to sign up
go ahead fill it
go ahead and start and fill it out while
if you could when I finished I can make
sure that the microphone is on uh
thank you Mr chairman my name is ciao
Kelly I'm from Hooksett New Hampshire
and I'm here to support this bill my
reason is
we shouldn't pay more taxes for this
business of putting this Trail here in
New Hampshire
my main concern is that it's increasing
easy traffic for criminals and all other
sources like homeless people that dump
into the city of Manchester in the state
of New Hampshire that create more
problems
for the taxpayers in the long run then
the business benefit
Ed by the people that's that against
this bill
you know so we need to protect
the safety of the Community First
and you know that's my main concerns
here besides I had to foot that bill too
so
against the Bill thank you for your time
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions from the committee seeing
oh sorry I used to help with the
Vietnamese community in New Hampshire
and Massachusetts and the thing that I
see firsthand in Boston is that this
criminals that just get out of Prisons
or homeless from different states they
just put them all on the train
and give them a one-way ticket and dump
them in this poor town in Boston like
Dorchester
and these poor towns stuck with these
criminals walking around their town with
needles and the children that's afraid
to go to school and women like me afraid
to walk to the bank and do our
businesses is scary they just dump your
prop their problems into your town so
easily so I'm scared of that for myself
and for the children thank you thank you
for your testimony there being no other
uh people interested in speaking at this
point I am going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 1432
at this time
we will hold the executive session at
some future date I want the committee to
carefully look at what has been
presented what we have gotten by via
electronic means and or mail and before
we have that discussion that said our
next meeting is at 1 15 with the
Department of Transportation to go over
the 10-year plan process and how the
what the availability of funds for that
once we uh get everything uh passed out
if everybody would take their seats
um
we could go ahead and get started we
have is
long or as little amount of time as we
need today
I did ask the commissioner and her staff
to come in and talk to us about the the
10-year plan process which a lot of the
returning members understand how that
process works
um but also to talk about money The
Color of Money which meaning they can
only be used for certain things as it
comes it becomes available
and
given the the vast amount of money that
was passed in the federal government
over the last year and a half or so
between American Rescue plan the
infrastructure plan
um how that has been incorporated into
our transportation planning before we
get into the real discussions next week
about the 10-year plan I have it
scheduled for next week assuming the
governor is going to meet his uh
statutory requirement to send us the
10-year plan by the 15th but commission
I appreciate you coming
and I know that uh
some of it for those of us who enter
some of the gas adheries may sound
repetitive but it is helpful and it is
being recorded live streamed the the
other committee members all have been
asked to to look at this at some point
um but it's a start and as I told the
committee just a minute ago we have as
long or as short as as they want to make
it as far as questions go with you I
please make sure the mic's on because we
you would like to spend with the dot
this afternoon we are here to hopefully
help you understand all the different
sources of revenue that fund the 10-year
plan and um
as you had requested um chair Graham We
have tried to make sure that we walk you
through all of the different modes of
transportation and as we talk about the
available funding we'll also touch on
the current condition of the system and
the level of service that we're able to
provide in the draft 10-year plan
you did reference that by Statute the
governor does need to deliver the
10-year plan to the legislature by
January 15th and we are
planning to deliver the plan to you
tomorrow it will be submitted on time
so thank you first of all for this
opportunity to be here today let me
introduce the do team the dot team
before we jump into the presentation
first of all we have our assistant
commissioner Bill Cass
for both the new members to this
committee and also returning members I'd
like you all to meet our new Deputy
Commissioner Andre Brier
and then beside me is uh Pete stamnus
who's our director of project
development
um Pete leads the 10-year plan effort
and he is the one that has um
presented at the 22 public meetings that
we had across the state um so it's only
fitting that Pete will be the one to
present today although we wanted to make
sure we had all the Commissioners
available for questions and then lastly
representing the department we have
Glenn Davison who is the project manager
for the 10-year plan he's the one that
actually works with the team to create
all the presentation materials and
everything that we passed out to you
today
so before we jump into the plan I do
just want to touch on what's happened
over the last couple of years with
respect to Transportation as you can
imagine the covid-19 pandemic really
impacted every aspect of the work that
we do and we were very relieved going
through the budget process last year
we've received a lot of support from the
governor in the legislature and so um
we'll touch today on the available
funding but really it's thanks to some
of the general funds that were added to
our budget as well as emergency relief
funds that we receive from the federal
government that we've been able to
continue with our core services
um there's several relief bills that
were passed providing funding to all of
the modes of transportation and so our
airports benefited from those relief
packages as well as the public transit
agencies and then in the later bills we
did receive some funding to offset
losses in our state highway revenues and
so we'll we'll touch very briefly on how
some of those funds impact the 10-year
plan and then of course most recently
the infrastructure investment and jobs
act the iija which the administration is
also calling the bipartisan
infrastructure law the bill so we
crisscross sometimes we'll call it bills
sometimes we'll call it iija from habit
but um it is the same piece of
legislation the bill that was passed
most recently to fund not only
Transportation infrastructure but other
types of infrastructure and we'll run
through those numbers this afternoon as
well so with that I'm going to turn it
over to Pete who's going to take you
through the presentation and the
materials in front of you are very
similar to the materials that we used
when we began this process with gasset
and we'll walk you through
the overview of the process and then
jump into all of the details so Pete
thank you commissioner
um
first I want to say that for those of
you who are
participating through the streaming
process this presentation that I'm going
to walk through in paper form has been
posted to our 10-year plan website and
if you Google
nhdot 10-year plan the web page will
come up and it's located right at the
top of the web page under
house Public Works and highways
committee presentation so it's available
there in PDF as well as all of the other
presentations that we've made and
supporting documentation
that we have provided over the course of
the last few months as we've been
traveling around the state given this
presentation through our hearing process
so with that
um uh we'll get started in in the
outline we've covered this pretty much
but I I we're going to spend a little
bit of time on the 10-year plan process
itself to refresh everyone about what it
is and how it proceeds
most of the work is going to be on The
Color of Money presentation and the
program review we'll have a couple
slides on on current state of the
infrastructure
um and and then there'll be a wrap-up
slide from there hopefully it'll be
about 20 minutes 25 minutes and um
we'll get started
um so on slide slide three uh there's a
graphic there 10-year plan process and
and the 10-year plan uh this is the
current 10-year plan coming the years 20
21 through 2030 and this is our work
plan it was approved in June of 2020 and
this guides our
um our all the work that we do at dot if
the project isn't listed here
individually or associated with a
program in this book we don't work on it
so it's it's again it's our work plan
and uh so it was approved the 21-30 plan
was approved last June and soon
thereafter we began the process to
update the plan uh for the next uh
10-year period which is uh 20 23 through
32.
and uh that began began with the
regional Planning Commission process
which is uh circled in red there where
um they reach out to their constituent
communities and
um solicit for projects and there's
debate internally they prioritize those
projects and make recommendations for
adding projects to the 10-year plan to
the DOT
dot takes those
um reviews them make sure that the scope
and budget are aligned and we provide
feedback to the regional planning
commissions and from there they've again
prioritized their recommendations from a
project standpoint and and submit those
to us in the spring in this case it was
the spring of 21.
from there we move into the gasset phase
Governor's advisory Commission on
Intermodal Transportation
um and that commission is the five
executive counselors and and the dot
commissioner and um through that process
we look to develop strategies to develop
a draft of the of the next update of the
10-year plan
um and we develop a draft and then we
bring it around uh the state and uh take
uh commentary and and and
um
testimony at hearings in this case we
did we held 21 public hearings across
the state and we had one all a virtual
public hearing to catch those who
weren't able to come we had many of the
public hearings that were also also had
a virtual component it worked fairly
well in most cases and we we gathered
lots of commentary and maybe there'll be
an opportunity at a future presentation
to share some of that with you
from there uh we finished the hearings
we um we discuss uh the commentary that
was received overall with gasset we make
some additional recommendations and
modify the plan that we came up with in
initially and then from there it goes uh
to the governor and the governor reviews
and updates and then they'll turn it
over to uh the house and this committee
and uh from and that's where we stand
right now hope to provide that
um and tomorrow
um and from there it's it you know it's
debated and and you make your
recommendations and and adjustments to
the plan and ultimately it gets assigned
into law by the governor uh this summer
in in June time frame so it's a two-year
process happens every two years a lot of
public input and uh overall I think it's
a really good process and I think every
everybody that's involved in it believes
it's a it's a good process
um
the
following two slides uh four and five
I'm not going to spend a lot of time on
them because those are basically the
specific dates and time periods that we
utilized or or actually happened from a
from a hearing process standpoint and so
you can you can that's that's for your
information
um and
we've got a couple of steps left here
but those give you the specific dates
so moving on to uh
slide six in in seven so The Color of
Money presentation
and slide slide deck
um
slide seven what you see there is a is a
table with a multi-colored uh headings
along the top this this table
is the same uh table that you received a
second uh copy of some of you got the
larger copies I thought it would be
helpful to have a separate piece because
we may want to refer back to this as we
go through the slide deck so that was
really the main purpose for giving you
the breakout table
this table
um
identifies the Investments included in
this case the draft 23 through 32 plan
by funding categories so each one of the
colors across the top is a different
category
and each one of these categories has
specific rules uh that go along with
them and how you can use the money and
where you can use the money and so
um this table if you start at the top
you look at the top and the road in
bridge mode and other modes
um so the other modes include rail
Transit and airport and that's 17
of the overall
um 4.6 billion dollar uh program the
road in bridge mode is 83 percent
of the uh of the pro of the program the
next the next
um uh category down from that in the in
the blue and the light purple
um is Highway funded and non-highway
funded so you'll see that the highway
funded portion
um overall makes up 69 percent of the
plan
and the balance is in the non-highway
funded portion of the plan
again
um each cell in this table identifies
the Investments included in the in the
draft 10-year plan for a particular
funding category and a particular fiscal
year
and each one of these is a summation of
of uh of the the book itself
um the the
just one quick clarification for for new
members or refresher for the veteran
members
that's the dollars that flow through the
state highway fund and so all of our
federal funds that we receive do go into
the state highway Fund in addition to
state revenue so that's why we describe
that as Highway funded whereas the
turnpike is a separate Enterprise and we
keep those funds and their own accounts
which is why we distinguish between
Highway funded and non-highway funded
but the highway funded really is the
federal funds as well as the state funds
just something for the new members to
consider
um so the other point that I want to
make here is the the federal funding the
fhwa funding on the far left side makes
up 83 percent
of of the uh the highway funded portion
it's a significant portion
um of the of the pot and it can't be
used for operations
or maintenance
um this uh plan is uh fiscally
constrained 4.6 billion dollars in
investment and right around 4.6 uh
little over
4.66 billion in revenue and that's also
captured at the bottom of the table
and so as the next series of slides will
review from right to left in this chart
the various categories so that you can
use your your separate sheet here if you
wanted to look at those and have that
separate as we go through the next
series of uh slides from a program
standpoint
microphone
how about now
I apologize folks
again just to
refresher I have a different
understanding of what a betterment is
could you I know there's going to be
another slide but can you just provide
okay
um so slide 18
um
the betterment program is funded with
three cents of the state gas tax okay so
it's approximately 22.5 million per year
as a slide articulates
um with
most of our state funds 12 comes off the
top that's what we call block ground Aid
and it goes back to cities and towns and
then the remainder of the funds are
available to the department to budget
for betterment type work so in this case
it's mostly minor bridge and drainage
repairs
um and some emergency repairs and the
vast majority of the money goes to what
we call the district resurfacing program
but we'll explain what we're funding
with federal funds will become clearer
how we then prioritize the state funds
thank you Mr chairman
um so back to uh slide eight airport
funding
um total of 382 million dollars
programmed in the draft 10-year plan and
again if you if you go to uh the the
Standalone chart and you look at the
airport category you'll see
381.99 million dollars at the bottom and
that's the number that I'm referencing
there and this will be consistent for
the next number of slides just so you
can connect the dots
the funding is primarily a Federal
Aviation Administration funding that's
Grant grants based it also has formula
apportionment
and funding is restricted for planning
studies preservation modernization or
expansion of eligible airport facilities
and it cannot be transferred to other
uses
New Hampshire eligible public UCA
reports uh the funding splits typically
90 FAA funds five percent State funds
and five percent local funds and there
are 14 projects in the draft tenure plan
listed by town and Airport name
the next slide uh just shows you a
little bit about the uh how the uh
airport locations are located around the
state
um there's
also additional for your information the
the uh the bound book that we provided
you the supplement that we had we made
up later earlier this summer has a lot
of this information from a mapping
standpoint that's a little bit a larger
scale so you can see them they're very
similar to the the plans uh that you
have uh tacked around on the walls
around the room
so they uh there's broke it up into two
uh two different categories federally
eligible airports or three commercial
airports located in Portsmouth
Manchester Lebanon and there were nine
publicly owned airports so they're all
listed here there's also 12 general
aviation airports that are not eligible
slide 10.
Transit funding it's a total of 378
million dollars program then the draft
uh funding primarily Federal Transit
Administration and the fundings
restricted for transit services uh
basically capital and operating
operating and planning and the funding
cannot be transferred to other uses
and this also includes the capital
Corridor project development phase uh
the map on the right shows you various
public transit services and again this
this map is in your uh supplement that
we passed out uh with the green cover on
it
so there are a
for funding categories on the on the
transit side uh and they're listed here
on Slide 11.
5307 5310 5311 and 53 39. so the 5307
funds urbanized area formula program for
uh uh Urban uh zone areas and it's for
operating preventive maintenance ADA
Paratransit Administration capital and
planning and the bullet below uh
identifies some of the entities that are
recipients of those funds
5310 seniors and individuals with
disabilities
uh it covers accessible Vehicles
Mobility management volunteer
Transportation purchases uh point of
service uh
services
and eligible uh Regional coordination
councils rccs and local government
non-profit Transit providers
5311 rural area formula program includes
inner city bus
and 5339 bus and bus facility program
again similar what what's eligible and
and who um is a recipient of those funds
it's also an additional 30 million
dollars uh three million dollars per
year transferred from Federal Highway
category to FTA for Transit
and just a note that there are four
urban areas Dover Rochester Portsmouth
talking small money but I noticed in the
state auction this year the uh I think
Boston Express buses that were auctioned
off got outrageous money does that go
back into this system or does it go to
the state
general fund
do we know I know they got I think 150
000 for one bus that had half a million
miles on it and it was more money they'd
purchase of buses
that debt service paid with General
funds that when we sell a bus the funds
go back to the general fund but we can
certainly validate that and check with
slide 12.
um just a little more on on the public
transit side
from a service standpoint there were 11
local Transit providers seven inner city
bus routes uh passenger rail services
are two part we have 25 Park and Ride
lots and uh the 197 communities are
covered by volunteer driver services
that's a big uh
um part of the services here and just
from a status standpoint we included
this in our overall public hearing slide
deck from demand response so those
limited services for the of our seniors
and and disabled uh generally service
frequency we find that the there it's
limited in the urban areas where there
is service so people are looking for
more and Route coverage
um where there isn't coverage is not
enough you know there's no there's
limited coverage in rural areas so those
are some of the things that we hear as
representative query
uh thank you chairman um
just on while we're on this page about
Park and Ride lots and all that kind of
stuff does this include uh the funding
of Staffing for those lots and the hours
that those like uh lot buildings are
open
so I think you're referring to our
welcome centers um rather than the park
and rides which don't have buildings or
facilities so we we classify them in two
categories there's the welcome centers
and then there's the park and rides the
welcome centers are actually staffed by
the
office of travel and tourism as part of
business and economic Affairs and the
funding for that goes through their
budget
follow-up
is does that would that include the the
station at the North Londonderry uh
parking ride lot
um that location so those are actually
Transit stations that's a third category
um so any of the locations where we have
bus service and a bus terminal we
actually enter into contracts with
a third party to provide those services
and so in the case of the 93 Corridor
that is done in partnership with Concord
Coach who also operate the Boston
express bus service on behalf of the
state
one more follow-up thank you
um and I guess when we enter when you
enter into those uh service agreements
do you have set categories for like what
they have to meet my my reason for
question is
um I traveled over over the Thanksgiving
break and
got to the north Londonderry station at
5 pm and there was no one uh no one
there and it was during a little bit of
a cold snap and many people were waiting
outside when there was the comfort of a
away from wind room that could have been
used had someone been there
so during the pandemic with the
ridership do
the cross the transit system we've had
to make some decisions around Staffing
to meet the need and so certainly as
we're seeing more people using Transit
again and using the commuter Services
down to Boston we are adjusting the
hours that the terminals are open and
staffed but we've been constantly
evolving as we see the ridership come
back
okay
moving on to rail funding and slide
13. again it's uh that's the last of the
other modes in the uh call out chart the
rainbow chart
total to 10.6 million dollar programmed
in the draft 10-year plan
um there's special railroad funding
approximately six hundred thousand
dollars per year primarily comes from
lease agreements with private rail
operators for use of state-owned rail
corridors and those funds are used for
maintenance and construction on
state-owned Rail lines and the funds
cannot be used for other needs it's also
railroad railroad revolving Loan Fund of
1.5 million every three years
so he's not a state bonded program for
Capital work on class three and uh Cog
railroads
the uh next slide slide 14
really highlights the uh the active
railroads in the state
for the state-owned railroad lines or
194 miles included in railroad operating
agreements there are 339 miles of
abandoned or inactive Rail lines and 365
miles of manage rail trail properties
New Hampshire has six railroad operators
under the under agreement to operate
services on the on these state-owned
lines at four freight services and two
tourists and Excursion services
slide 15 state-owned rail Trails again a
map shows the location of these trails
and they uh
includes about 365 overall miles of
managed trails and 224 miles are are
managed by D.O.T and the balance of
those are managed by uh natural cultural
we've gone to uh slide 16. Turnpike
system the graphic at the right shows
identifies the three uh Turnpike
segments in in New Hampshire
you've got the uh the uh Everett blue
star and Spalding
overall the three segments include 89
miles of of uh of Interstate
172 Bridges and uh nine toll facilities
and as the commissioner mentioned before
the turnpike system it's an Enterprise
fund so all revenue collected on the
turnpike from tolls must be used on the
overall Turnpike Revenue uh pays for a
number of of things the numbers that are
quoted here are from uh fiscal year 2021
operation and maintenance and
enforcement it's 43 million
Debt Service 39 million
uh renewal and Rehabilitation work
around 20 million and uh Capital
Improvements which is the balance of the
uh of the revenue that's collected is
used on Capital Improvements
approximately 14 million dollars in 2021
there was 103 million dollar
transactions with about 113 million
dollars in toll Revenue collected Are We
thank you for the clarification Mr
chairman
oh
um the next slide slide 17 uh again
looks at the the the general Turnpike
programs uh some of which uh both all
both of the listings here on this slide
are mentioned in the previous slide so
the turnpike renewal and replacement
program trr
um and this draft is around 15 million
dollars per year and it's used to
preserve maintain and upgrade the
existing Turnpike infrastructure
um
the uh r r uh program is is required by
a bond resolution and it really covers
the work that's necessary to keep the
turnpike system in in the high level of
service
annual resurfacing programs about seven
million dollars per year and and uh the
balance of uh that program goes to
fridge painting Bridge Rehabilitation
work and other Associated roadway uh
improvements from a drainage guardrail
signage and such
um the Capital Improvements
um again these are funded as at the uh
at the end of the revenue Stream So from
a waterfall standpoint the last uh piece
that gets funded is a is capital
projects and uh this piece of the slide
really shows you the uh projects that
are included currently in in this draft
and they're listed there there's a
there's uh five separate projects uh
provides you uh the the location of the
project the overall uh
funds included in in the 10-year plan
the turnpike funds are included in the
10-year plan and the a year that those
improvements are funded from a
construction standpoint so General
Sullivan Bridge Rehabilitation
um the average Turnpike widening from
Nashua uh to Bedford Manchester exit six
and seven reconstruction
um and the beau conquered I-93 widening
project the listing here includes uh
because it's multi-funded it has some
federal funds with it so the numbers
here really identify the the turnpike
funding included in in the project
um and uh the basically the turnpike
portion is south of uh louder south of
Exit 14
i-89 and north of that point is
federally funded uh total overall cost
for the project is 375 million dollars
and the completion date is 2033 in this
draft
um also uh all electronic tolling is
included uh Dover Rochester which was uh
is currently under construction that's
the uh conversion of the Dover and
Rochester tolls to all electronic
tolling that should be completed
um in in a couple of years and also
included in the in the draft is the
conversion of uh potential conversion of
Bedford tolls
um
representative boys
thank you Mr chairman regarding
regarding the trr what type of a grading
system or what type of uh
protocols do you use to prioritize the
work as it relates to the program that
uh all of the roads we drive all the
roads with a van from a from a uh from a
payment condition standpoint we also do
inspections on all the the bridges
um and and through those uh through
those inspections we identify priorities
um to to do the improvement work so
there there's various levels of of
service
um and condition along the turnpike and
and there are some areas that need
attention sooner than others and and we
try to prioritize that
um with the r r program so we don't
they're not long looking uh projects
generally it's a it's a program where we
identify those um those needs and create
projects and address them in that
fashion
so slide 18 state
we talked a little bit about betterment
again it's three cents on the state gas
tax uh the 22 state gas tax raises
approximately 22.5 million dollars per
year
um the first 12 percent goes to block
grant Aid
um there's a district resurfacing uh
program and and Bridge and drainage
repairs and emergency repairs and
discretionary Force kind of work is uh
covers the balance of the betterment
SB 367
4.2 cents uh on state gas tax collects
approximately 32 million dollars per
year again the first 12 percent
goes to block grant Aid
the next and and this uh
this chart and the next table this tape
this this slide in the next table go
along with one another so we'll be we'll
you know you'll be able to reference
back and forth here so uh from a
waterfall standpoint the next uh the
next category for use of these funds is
I-93 uh Debt Service so
um SB 367
funded a provided the revenue to fund a
200 million dollar uh loan to finish
I-93 Salem to Manchester
um and this the the increase uh
currently initially was used to
pay debt uh interest only on that loan
and there'll be more evident in the
waterfall chart in the next slide uh
currently uh through 2025 we're paying
2.2 million dollars in interest
um and in in 2026 we will be paying full
uh principal and interest on that on
that note through 2034.
the next category uh for SB 367 revenue
is State Bridge aid program for for
municipal Bridges
um through 2025 6.8 million dollars of
SB 367 Revenue goes to that program
and after uh by 2026 through 2032 uh the
program is reduced based on the revenue
uh projected Revenue collections from
the gas tax
uh 4.9 million to 3.3 million from 20 uh
26 to 2032.
and then the uh the last uh category uh
for SB 367 in the waterfall chart is the
tipia Pledge Paving and redless redless
bridges
so by deferring uh principal payments on
the on the uh the Tiffany note and
tiffia stands for transportation
infrastructure Finance Innovation act so
it's a federal it's a Federal Loan
program that we um
um we got into for a low interest loan
to finish that construction effort and
part of the uh part of the uh the
structure of that loan was that we were
able to use the um the the the principal
defer principal payments uh to make
investments on Rural roads and bridges
and so
um through 2025 there's about 20 million
dollars per year uh that's used to pave
rural roads and bridges and in 2026 that
goes away so there's a you know 20
million dollars that we've been
investing in those rural roads uh and
and bridges that will will no longer be
available
moving to um
slide 19 and I said this this waterfall
is what we call the SB 367 waterfall
chart and what you'll see is each row
represents a fiscal a fiscal year
and moving left to right total revenue
from the 4.2 cents uh collected is shown
in that in that second column
um the 12 off the top for the grant for
block grant Aid is shown next
um The Debt Service on the tiffia note
is shown in the next column and you'll
see
um I've highlighted in red the area of
this current draft 10-year plan so for
the next couple of years we're at 2.2
million dollars per year in debt service
and that's the interest only and then in
2026 we start paying uh all uh principal
next category that receives funding is a
state aid for municipal Bridges
and you'll note again it's highlighted
for this uh 23 through 32 draft 10-year
plan period
it's through 31 in this case but so it
begins with a 6.8 million and as the the
projected Revenue decreases this is
where we're going to see a decrease in
the program level for funding for state
aid uh bridges on the municipal side so
it runs again it begins at 6.8 million
generally matched with with a 20 match
by the municipality and then it's
reduced to 3 3.3 million in
2032 again because of the projections
that we have received from uh road tow
moving on uh I do have one clarifying
question on the whole
um
waterfall
it is my understanding that you're using
projections that show Revenue coming in
over time going down
at the same time we're looking at the
sunset of 4.2 cents and whatever that
all breaks into the system at the end of
yes um
for the return
we had actually hired a Consulting team
who helped us forecast Revenue over a
longer Horizon Department of Safety
collects the highway fund revenue and
they as part of the budget process of
course work closely with the legislature
and near-term forecasts but we had hired
a consulting firm to help us anticipate
how revenues will continue to climb with
fuel efficiency of vehicles increasing
as well as more hybrid electrical
electric vehicles entering the fleet and
so that's what we're showing in that
second column is declining Revenue over
time from this funding source but then
also as you mentioned Representatives
later on when we Sunset the tiffia
pledged work to start paying the
principal on the loan that further
reduces our capacity to pave the rural
roads
thank you Mr chairman
um
I guess I'm perplexed at the deferral of
the of the
principal payments uh I don't understand
why you did that
I do understand why you did it I don't
I don't understand the logic behind it
described so if we had used traditional
bonding to finish the work on I-93
we estimate we would have spent an
additional 20 million or more in
financing this particular Loan program
we got the lowest interest rate at that
time it was 1.09 percent but the reason
we qualified for that low interest rate
is because we pledged to do this rural
work and stretch the value of this new
Revenue source to not only finish one
large-scale project in the southern part
of the state but also bring benefit to
the rural communities as well and so
basically we're somewhat hedging against
inflation by paying interest only the
federal government
rewarded us with a very low interest
rate as long as we in the near term
we're spending the money on the rural
roads and bridges and we ended up
actually replacing or rehabilitating 23
Red List bridges over this period of
time where we've been paying the
interest only so overall it was a very
attractive
loan term and we've certainly seen the
benefits across the state and in a few
minutes we'll talk about the condition
of the infrastructure you'll see how
dramatically our pavement condition in
particular has changed over that period
and follow-up Mr chairman
um I understand that
um I guess what I what doesn't make a
lot of sense to me is you're telling us
that we're projecting our revenues to
drop dramatically over the next few
years and you're tagging that money on
to the those years
the discount you take up front for
paying only the interest it's going to
go on the end of the loan where we're
going to have significantly less Revenue
[Music]
reduction
worth the price we're going to pay in
the end
as I said before in total when you look
at the full amount associated with the
Tiffy alone we will pay less than we
would have with traditional bonding
because the interest rate was so much
lower we actually saved you know at
least 20 million dollars more it would
have depended on the exact rates the
time that we secured a traditional Bond
as to how much exactly we would have
saved but we estimate we saved 20
million over the life of the loan
further we then were able to do this
bridge work sooner and hedge against
inflation so we were able to do those
projects in today's dollars versus
having to defer some of that bridge work
so there were savings from that respect
as well okay thank you very much and and
just so everybody remembers that when we
did the 4.2 cents there was a sunset in
the law
that was not tied to Tiff or anything
else it was just going to sunset at a
certain year
by structuring it this way the
department was able to leverage
additional funding in the early years
for Paving and Bridge repair and the
rest
by deferring some of the principle
knowing that we're still going to have
the 4.2 cents coming in even at a
reduced rate enough to pay off the bond
but it was the only way we were going to
get
um
the interstate finished the bridge is
done and still keep the any kind of
Revenue coming in at the time and I was
one of the sponsors of that bill and it
the other uh
um with regards to the date it aligns
well with the completion of The Debt
Service on the Garvey bonds for I-93
also so it's more it leveled The Debt
Service payment over time
different color of money but it you know
from an overall Debt Service load
um it leveled that out also so it was
all well coordinated from an overall
moving on to uh slide 20.
so the State Bridge aid program
provides State funds to municipalities
for bridges for their own uh their
municipally owned Bridges
early on it's eight and a half million
dollars total per year with a 20 match
required by the municipality and that's
through 2025 and the projection to
decline to uh you know somewhere around
the four million dollar range by 2032 so
that's the same fund that we talked
about in the previous two slides
currently there are 113 Bridges enrolled
and initially
um they were through 2029 and 65 of
those are are red listed or poor
conditioned Bridges
the average cost across those 113
Bridges around 1.4 million dollars per
year Just for information purposes
um it's a pretty popular program we do
expect to conduct a new solicitation to
add new projects
um in in the near future which would be
wrapped into the next 10-year Plan
update
and um as part of the draft we have
included
um a new program
um that's that's been proposed for
municipally owned Bridges um it's called
mobile and we're using some of the off
system Federal Bridge
funds to fund that program and so that's
included in the draft and we'll talk
more about that down the road in maybe a
work session or another presentation but
that is included in in the draft and it
was something that
um was recommended through the gossip
moving on to slide 21
funding eligibility this is you know
where we can use the money
um
so we look at all the the uh the road
mileage and we have fed Aid eligible
roads around 3 700 miles across the
state and there's also 1500 plus miles
of non-eligible roadways
um
and so this from a from a a funding
standpoint once The tiffia Pledge on the
paving is complete
um in 2025 they'll be Paving on Rural
world to be significantly reduced most
of our again the majority of our funding
is uh through Federal
um reauthorization and through the
federal program and there are many miles
of roads in New Hampshire that are not
eligible for those federal funds
um
and again the uh this is kind of a
repeat but the betterment program and
the tifia pledge for the SB 367 exists
for state roads not supported with
federal aid so that's where those that
those dollars are being directed
um and and you know that 20 million
dollars that we have that ends to go to
pay uh the the full Debt Service on that
note goes away in 2026 and and those uh
rural roads are gonna
um beware the the reduction in work
moving to uh on with the on the federal
uh side slide 22.
so what we have in this table is a a
breakdown of the iija which is the new
reauthorization act on the federal side
um so there's there's a lot of talk in
in the news about the two additional two
billion dollars included for New
Hampshire
um in this in this reauthorization and
you'll see that First Column for the
years 22 through 26 it's a five-year
reauthorization
the bottom line total is a little over 2
billion dollars
um and in in the upper half of that you
look
um so what's included in in that bill
for Highway programs is
1.139 billion there's a new bridge
program a five-year program for 225
million there's also an electric vehicle
charging program for 17
million dollars
there's also funds for public
transportation in airports
so if you compare that total the 1.6
1.558 billion dollar total to what we uh
what was in the previous reauthorization
Act of 1 billion the balance you
subtract those column two from column
one you get 545 million dollars in new
money so that's the new money that we're
talking about
um that's available and included uh for
the most part in the draft 10-year plan
that we have here today
so you'll recall one of the topics
during the last 10-year Plan update was
around the revenue assumptions so the
fast act our prior Federal authorization
was scheduled to end
and so we had worked with both the
gasset committee and then with the
legislature
um to estimate what Revenue would have
in the future so for federal funds we
had assumed level funding and so that's
why we're
we're not adding 1.6 billion dollars
worth of projects to the 10-year plan we
already had actually a billion dollars
worth of projects programmed because
we'd assumed level funding and so as we
worked with the executive Council we
were really only adding the 545 million
dollars worth of new projects or adding
funding to projects Etc so we'll get
into all the detail when we have future
work sessions but we wanted you to have
that point of reference
and just for clarification commissioner
when we get into the plan and the couple
work sessions that we have uh scheduled
to go over individual projects and the
rest things like the money for EV
charging will be a separate discussion
at that point okay thank you because I'm
sure that a lot of us have some
questions about that
so when you see the 10-year plan you'll
understand what we did but essentially
we've added a program for EV charging
into the 10-year plan booklet we're
still waiting for a lot of the federal
guidance and so we'll talk about that as
well in terms of the rules around
spending the new categories of funds but
we did establish the programs based on
what we know and the amount of money
thank you Mr chairman commissioner nice
to see you
the so as wonderful as that sounds 545
million dollars if we compare that to
our other states in our country where
um so that's a difficult question to
answer oh come on
so with respect to the traditional
Highway programs unfortunately the
Congress did not adjust the formulas so
when it comes to the core Highway
programs we still receive the least
funding of all of the states
in some of the new categories we
actually get a little bit more because
they established a lower limit on how
much each state should receive so we
received as an example 225 million for
the bridge program which was more per
capita than some other states because
there was a specific threshold set for
that but the core programs what this
committee is used to discussing with us
the highway programs we still receive
the least and those are the programs
that we would anticipate continuing
Beyond this five-year Bill and we'll
again we'll get into all of the revenue
assumptions for the 10-year plan but
this Federal bill was only through 2026
so we worked with the Council on
forecasts for the second half of the
10-year plan and things like the bridge
program we think those are going to be
one time for this five-year window so we
have not continued them into the future
thank you over the over the Long Haul we
do receive the lease through the
um
so uh the uh
second to last uh column there uh it
says in draft 10-year plan so there and
and the last column is not in draft so
there are some funds that have not been
uh included in the draft because we
didn't have uh information on them
um and so as we learn more
um those
um those will be addressed and included
in the plan but right now
um what's included is the one 1.5
billion dollars
moving on to slide 23 this gives you a
little bit of flavor for the uh the uh
the different
um
funding categories within the federal
Realm of the Federal Highway funding so
we have primary funding for Highway and
bridges and there's also some mandated
Federal funding and each one of these is
a different
program from a funding standpoint
and it breaks out the the basic
apportionment in this case uh for each
one of these funds for 2023
and gives you a sense for where where
those programs are there are two new uh
programs that were included in the
primary funding side a carbon Reduction
Program of 5.2 million dollars per year
and uh of the protect uh uh program or
which is focused on resiliency on the
roadway and Bridge Network about 5.9 a
um there there's a mandated Federal
funding
um with different programs here and
you've heard these These are the these
are retained those are the CMAC or
congestion mitigation and air quality
program The Rail Highway Crossings
program and also the hsip or highway
safety Improvement program and the
apportionments for those programs are
listed here
um
so as I mentioned before each program
contains specific requirements on on how
and where the money can be used many of
them come with a population-based uh um
criteria in them
um and overall the New Hampshire uh
received on average around at least in
2023 it's 223 million dollars of
apportionment and it's about a 24
increase overall we had constrained the
current 10-year plan at 183 million
dollars per year on the federal side
from a from a Federal Highway funding
standpoint
okay uh slide 24 and slide 25.
um we've always included a brief
discussion on on Turnpike toll credits
in our Color of Money presentation
as we get lots of questions about
um Turnpike toll credits and and what
um so uh we've tried to be very specific
about how we explain this in in uh in in
this slide so I'm just I'm I'm gonna uh
I'm gonna read this
um so we earn the D.O.T earns toll
credits uh when uh State funds basically
Turnpike toll revenues used uh to uh
complete work on facilities that serve
interstate commerce so the entire
Turnpike system is eligible
um and basically it goes to uh the
expenditures in the capital program and
the r r program
and so these toll credits are earned
um and they're they can be used as a
soft match that will allow us instead of
making that 20 cash cash match to the
federal funds typically it's 80 fed 20
State we're able to use these toll
credits to effectively leverage 100
percent of the federal funds
um they we we don't get any additional
authority obligational authority uh from
a federal standpoint we still use what
we have however it allows us to make
that soft match because of those
investments in areas that aren't
um utilizing federal funds otherwise
um so and I explained the the uh the
advantage of of total credits
um we can use 100 federal funds um when
there is no State funds to make the
match
um and otherwise if we didn't have that
state match or the toll credits we
wouldn't be able to take advantage of
the of the federal funds so that that's
that's definitely an advantage
all but one of the drawbacks is is it
reduces the overall program by 25
um so if if State funds were used as a
match uh the 20
um the 223 million dollars that we have
um in 2020 uh in 2023 would amount to a
278 million dollar program so it's a
um I I included the uh uh total credit
uh projection uh table in in the next
slide um this gets updated on on a
fairly regular basis
and currently
um currently and as of 2021 there's
about 195 million uh dollars in uh total
credit balance
um and the red numbers show the
projections uh based on what we are
aware of at the at the the time that
this was as of October 19th 2021.
at a future meeting not right now
um a certain state senator keeps
bringing up a pilot program about
selling toll credits I would like that
to be brought up as a point of
discussion with the committee but we
don't need to do it today and what it
means and the rest and I don't know if
it's even too late for us to apply for
the pilot program
so the language establishing the pilot
program was included in the iija that
was just passed so there is very little
information available on how that
program will actually be administered
New Hampshire certainly has interest
in being part of the program
but there are some drawbacks and
certainly you know
there's different thoughts around how
many total credits we should retain and
why we would want to keep those balances
at a certain level and the other thing
that we'll dig into if we do a
presentation on this topic specifically
is you'll notice that
those criterias to other tool credits
are even available in certain years so
foreign
a couple more uh slides to go through
moving into
um state of the infrastructure uh slides
and just as a as a review
um our state roadway Network and this is
on on Slide 27.
um we have categorized the various
levels of a roadway as tiers so tier one
through tier four uh tier one and two
are Statewide Transportation corridors
higher volume higher speeds
um you know tier one or interstates and
divided highways in tier two a major
Statewide corridors the mileage for each
one of those tiers is identified
on the slide and then tier three and
four are more Regional corridors and
local connectors again moderate speeds
moderate traffic moderate to low traffic
volumes and the mileage for each one of
those tiers
um are listed here and many of the I
guess all of the uh
roadway miles that are not eligible for
federal funds can be found on the tier
so moving moving to the next slide
and what we what we've done here is try
to provide some sense for how the the
road uh the the road surface conditions
are changing over time
by each one of the the tiers so again
tier one is the higher volume the
interstates tier four are the more local
connector roads and each one of these
tiers has
um four sets of of data in them ranging
from pavement condition from uh the 17
to 26 10-year plan
through the one without the gray shading
which is the 23 through 32 tenure this
draft 10-year plan uh period so again
this is
um every two years every year we we
drive every every Road in the state and
we measure the condition of those roads
and we assign a a roughness index to it
and
um there are different grades in that
um so good is a has an iri of of less
than 95 and very poor is has an iri of
larger than 350 and so you can see as
you go from the higher volume roads we
those try to keep those in in pretty
pretty good shape there's over 90
percent good as you go down in tier you
see the condition how it's changed and
but what also you can see from this
chart is the investment that we've been
making over time and a lot of it's
specifically due to the the state level
of investment with SB 367 and that
tiffia pledge you'll note that the
condition has improved significantly
over this time period if you look at
tier three and tier four
um overall you can see that that
improvement over time so currently where
we stand uh tier one 96 percent of the
roads are in
um good condition and our Target that
we've set is 95 so we've we've we've
we've met our Target
on tier two 92 percent are in good or
for fair condition and our Target is 90
90 percent and that has was increased by
five percent so we've we've improved by
five percent over the last round of the
10-year plan uh the levels that we had
tier three
we are 80 go to fair and our Target's 80
percent and that's up four percent
um from the last uh time we uh um we uh
made these charts and uh uh tier four
um 62 and go to fair condition the
target's 65 and that's actually
um
uh uh declined a bit since the last time
overall
um
the overall the the Statewide network is
in is in is in really good shape
um 80 good Affair that's that's uh
that's that's really good
um and it's up over one percent
um in uh since the previous round
um but there's also 805 miles that are
in poor very poor condition and those
we've improved that we've reduced the
number of Road mileage that is in uh
poor a very poor condition since the
last round so overall we're in pretty
good shape on the roadway side
um and we need to you know pay attention
to the other years on the state
investment side uh because
um as you see in the next slide slide 29
this covers both
um uh
Road and Bridge conditions so on the at
the top half of the slide there is a is
a chart a chart there that shows miles
of Road resurfaced over time and it goes
from 2013 out to 2031 and in the middle
there the the line that's shown changes
color from black to Blue so the black
portion of the left-hand side of that
shows actual miles paved on the
Statewide Network
and the blue shows what we project to be
able to pave with the investment level
that we have currently in the draft
10-year plan
and note that we've got a a Target
mileage of 500 miles plus a minus there
and that's what we're trying to uh pave
any year and so we've got about 5 000
miles of of a road on the Statewide
Network try to get into a 10-year cycle
um so 500 miles is 10 is uh uh 10 of
that and so we try to hit that so we get
on on a 10-year cycle
and if we can pave
more than 500 Miles we're going to keep
the roads in in pretty good shape if we
can't you're going to see a decline in
the condition
um so overall the conditions for the
next four years are expected to be good
above 80 percent go to fair and that's
above average
in the later years because of the the
reduction in Miles paved that we are
projecting
um
we're expected to decline by 30 to about
50 percent good affair
and again the tier three and four roads
are expected to decline the most with
the anticipated decreases in state funds
so that's again
um number of miles pave matters and
certainly
um we we make up more ground by
investing Paving on those rural roads
um
Below on the second the bottom half of
the the slide is a
a graphic that shows some State uh the
number of uh bridges on the state
um uh Red List
and so a bridge makes it on to the Red
List when it's one of its three major
elements receives a four out of uh uh
one one out of ten receives a four it's
a it's a considered poor condition and
it makes it on to the red list and and
Bridges State bridges are inspected uh
once every two years when they make it
on the Red List they're inspected once
every six months so twice a year
and this graphic shows the numbers of
bridges on the Red List over time and
you see that
[Music]
um
as we go from solid red to the the blue
dash again right now we're at 118
bridges on the state red list and with
the investment level that we have
included in the draft 10-year plan we
expect to push that down to 91 by the
end of this draft 10-year plan period by
by 2033.
[Music]
um
the
um just one just one question on that
projection is that part of a zero-sum
game as one comes off and or ten come
off and two go on as or are we just
starting with the number and saying
we're fixing this number and it'll go to
91.
we look at a number of different uh
approaches to project how many bridges
are going to come on to the red list and
we use some rolling averages over the
previous uh five years and we we do a
couple of things and try to settle on
um what we think is is
um you know reasonable to assume
um in some cases
um in the past we've assumed that you
know 14 are going to come on and and 14
didn't come on so that you know part of
part of that also is it's difficult to
predict how our investments on the
preservation side for Bridges is
affecting the deterioration of the
bridges in general so we've been
investing a lot of money on bridge
preservation and uh by doing that we're
slowing the rate of the the degradation
of the condition of the bridges and
thereby reducing the number of bridges
that are coming on the red list so we're
attacking it at both ends and it's it's
been fairly successful and it and and I
believe it's the right approach uh to
take to make those smaller Investments
early
um as opposed to waiting to um the worst
first type of approach where it takes a
lot more money to take that bridge off
off the red list and to correct the
deficiencies
um
I guess my question is
with relationship to the with the
relatives of the Red List Bridges
which ones are coming off as far as
areas
um I represent kowas County
and uh I guess what I'm concerned with
is are the all the bridges on the
southern end of the state getting more
attention than the bridges in the
I I would ask that
specific questions be held this was
supposed to be just an orientation on
Color of Money and the rest we will have
two hearings and two full days of work
sessions on this plan to answer those
specific questions right now we don't
have the plan in front of us to even
look at and I understand your concern
for anything north of The Notches you
would and the former chairman of this
committee we're always concerned about
that
um
but I think it's unfair to the to the
commissioner to try to answer questions
when we don't have
everything in front of us to look at
what is what is being done and in what
the thing I will say is that we strive
for equity in terms of the condition
across the system so we have a bridge
prioritization process so not only do we
inspect these Bridges but we're required
to rank them in order of priority and so
it's not about how much we're spending
in each region of the state we want all
of the bridges that are on the
interstate system to be in a good state
of repair whether that's a bridge on 93
in Littleton or we're talking about a
bridge on 93 in Manchester and then
likewise as you go down to tiers that
Pete described tier one tier two tier
three and we're striving for the equity
across the state in that classification
of roadway and therefore the importance
of the bridge as we translate it into
the bridge world and we'll get into all
of that detail if it's something the
and and
uh that really concludes the our
presentation there's a slide here that I
identified some topics that we could
cover on the next presentation I'm sure
we'll be in uh coordination and
communication
um with with you to make sure that we uh
come prepared for the next couple of
meetings
um and we will
um we'll be able to answer all the
questions and provide you the
information that you seek
at next week on the 19th in the
afternoon we have the first public
hearing on House Bill 2022.
at that time I would
like the department to present
a high level of what is in the plan
um adjustments that were made because of
an increased Federal funding and
adjustments that were made as a result
of the gas adhering sort of like you did
at the last gas at hearing that kind of
level
so that we can start and that the public
can hear what what the broader public
and then whoever is in here to testify
also understands what we're starting
with before we
from those that want to testify you know
how long would you like us to present
for recognizing that will be the day of
the Public Public hearing and you want
to hear their testimony more than I I
would suggest no more than 30 minutes
and
um
that I would ask the committee to hold
off on the question so the department
representative query
um yeah so I had uh one question that
stemmed from uh yesterday's Bill hearing
on
um sound barriers and so one thing that
arised from that was the uh process in
check and see which areas qualify and so
I was hoping that the committee could
get a copy of
that um
procedure and then also I know that uh
uh Mr Cass said that there were some
areas that we have more control over and
then there are some areas that the
federal side regulates
um and if if you could make note of what
those where we can't touch and where we
I I think you're you're looking for the
rules that and criteria that the
department uses for
um evaluating what what areas are
eligible for Sovereign barriers am I
you can get copies of I think what
you're asking for is essentially our uh
our noise policy which spells out the
criteria in the process um
online but I can certainly get hard
copies here at the starting point yeah
and I think that would be helpful Bill
if if members of the committee could see
that because the whole sound barrier
issue is not going to go away it's not
going to go away as we go through the
representative Boyd
thank you Mr chairman uh commissioner
and assistant commissioner P because I
missed your last name
similar to the question that I asked
previously regarding turnpike's is there
a
protocol a program regarding how you
grade what and prioritizing how roads
get paved in the system the ones in the
twos like I I kind of would expect a
more was kind of looking at the
tier three in the tier four roads and I
was just you know if unless it's a broad
stroke kind of thing I just would
appreciate some insight thank you so the
tier three and four roads are typically
funded with the betterment funds that
we've discussed earlier and in the
betterment law it does describe how the
funds are to be allocated across the
state
um as I mentioned earlier in response to
representative Thompson's question we're
striving for Equity from a condition
perspective and so we'd worked with this
Committee in the past to have a little
bit more latitude and the cost of doing
business can vary across the state and
so
we start by dividing the funds equally
but then we have a certain amount that
is held back so that we can add funding
in this particular region of the state
as we strive for that equity in terms of
condition so as Pete mentioned we drive
all the roads we measure the condition
and then we put together these Paving
plans and we'll get into all of that
detail at a later date with the
committee we do a three-year Paving plan
of all the segments we plan to pave in
each region based on the initial amounts
of money and then we level things out to
try and raise the condition across the
entire system
oh Mr chairman so
I appreciate the equity piece
and I look forward to reading what what
that you go out you go out and you look
at it at a variety of variety of
different roads
and it you use the you break you split
the money evenly and then you prioritize
based on which which bucket of money is
available for a specific specific SEC
you know specific section of the dot
within I guess on there I'll narrow it
down within we'll just say one section
do you do you have a program that says
we paved this particular Road on on such
a such a date we give it a grade of we
went from an I'll talk in transportation
terms we went from a level of service
from F to D do you have something like
that as it relates to your Paving
program uh with the set within the
sections of the dot for any segment of
roadway we can tell you how the
condition has changed over time and we
also track the projects that we
completed
um so
our pavement management section has all
of that data at their fingertips and so
we also were able to assess how
successful different treatments are
because we know when we last paved with
that treatment and then how much life
expectancy we got
um our industry has come a long way in
terms of forecasting condition
several years ago in one of the federal
bills map 21 we were required to start
producing Transportation Asset
Management plans so we're a lot more
data driven in terms of not just
measuring condition but then also using
all of that data to forecast how the
system is going to perform over time and
so the veterans on this committee will
understand some of our forecasting was
rather crude maybe two or three ten year
plan Cycles ago but we're becoming more
and more sophisticated every time
because we're collecting more data so we
have more of that information on
deterioration rates
just a quick follow-up last follow Mr
chairman thank you so is there a
dashboard on the dot website that has
the road that you're interested in
we have some of the charts here today
and uh
you know the committee's will will pull
together whatever additional data or
statistics you'd like to see
commissioner I appreciate you candle
thank you thank you Mr chairman you're
welcome and I think the the piece that a
lot of the public
has a hard time grasping is that there's
the federal eligible the non-federal
eligible the turnpike system which can't
use any federal funds but that we have
uh
criteria be being held against it by the
bondholders to do certain things with
the turnpike that is above and beyond
what may happen the tier three and four
roads
so that's a piece that we all have to
get a grasp on so that we can explain it
not only to our constituents but to our
fellow Representatives who really don't
dig into the 10-year plan or how it's
funded they just know that there's
a billion dollars out there and why is
as we um you know wrapped up we showed
you the condition of the system and one
of the questions we get often is it
looks like you're making great strides
with respect to Bridge condition you
know why aren't you taking some of the
money and spending it on Pavements but
you know as we've tried to describe
today
we can use federal funds even on some of
the what they call off system Bridges
but we can't use federal funds on off
system roadways and so
um I always say to this committee that
you're really prioritizing projects
within each of these categories as
opposed to looking at all of our
transportation needs and
prioritizing Things based on where we
have the worst condition or
um
and we believe the investment should be
made because it's it's all going to be
done in compliance with the laws around
the one thing I want to Circle back to
representative Eden's question about the
Surplus process and when we sell
equipment the folks in Maryland Transit
did Circle back with us and I was
mistaken the funding is restricted when
we sell a bus that has passed its useful
life we are able to take that money and
put it back into a Transit account and
use it for the rest of our Transit
programs
representative query
um I will just stay I'm not sure if this
is the appropriate time so I look to
your guidance Mr chair if this is
appropriate
um I had a couple constituents reach out
to me uh due to the ice storm that we
saw last week with some of the issues of
were we unprepared for the 90 the state
of condition that 93 was going to be in
or were we really just kind of caught
off guard by how bad that storm was
mainly a lot of people were saying well
why did it take an hour and a half to
to get the road salted and and gritted
why wasn't it gridded prior to that so
perhaps
uh clarification so I can answer knowing
that the department is is uh tight when
it comes to plow plowing and all that
kind of stuff so every winter weather
event is different it all comes down to
the type of precipitation the time of
day as well as uh
the road temperatures and the air
temperatures so we've had a lot of this
wintry mix freezing rain turning over to
sleet and unfortunately we haven't had
that much snow it's actually easier for
us to plow and treat during snowstorms
I think the day that you're referring to
um
when the precipitation first started you
could barely see that rain was falling
it was um almost like a mist and so we
had been out treating earlier in the
morning but there hadn't been enough
traffic when we put salt out it takes
some time for that salt to break down
and work into the roadway and so as the
traffic volumes picked up it was just
the worst possible situation the
temperatures were such that um we'd had
a very cold spell the road was extremely
cold and then the air temperature was
warming and so when it started as a fine
Mist I think motorists didn't even
realize it was doing anything and they
were still driving at the faster speeds
so we got caught a little bit with a
couple of accidents early on from
individuals who just were driving too
fast for the conditions because the
storm was just beginning and then trying
to get our trucks through and then treat
segments once you've had some accidents
is challenging even though you know when
we're right at the accent scene law
enforcement can help us get in it was
just several factors the time of day
with the traffic building and so we were
out there
there's been a number of Articles even
in newspapers and neighboring states I
think Connecticut experienced the same
thing parts of Massachusetts and you can
go just 10 miles over and the it's a
slightly warmer air temperature and a
very different road conditions and so it
is challenging for our team and once we
have some accents is out there like I
said that's a another hurdle that we
have to overcome and trying to get to
the locations and we can't have a
knee-jerk reaction and take a truck and
send it to where we're hearing a report
of icing because that would leave other
roads untreated so we try to keep to our
beats and our routes as much as we can
so we just ask everyone you know always
to pay attention to the weather that
morning I know I stepped out onto my own
driveway it looked like it was dry and
it was very very slick of course it was
not treated like our roads were so there
thank you and uh commissioner we
appreciate you and the team being here
it was helpful to get started on
understanding some of the changes in the
funding especially
um since as you are finishing up the
gassed hearings and trying to finalize
the uh the draft 10-year plan Congress
who is finally passing the
reauthorization bill with additional
funding in it so it it is helpful for us
to have a start point of understanding
where you are and as you know with this
committee once we get into the actual
well why is this and this year uh why
was this dropped or why was it moved
back
those questions will all come from not
just us but there will be be addressed
to us by members of of the public
whether our own constituents are not but
it's been helpful to have you here and
at least get us started before the first
public hearing and I've I I personally
appreciate it thank you
um I think this committee is an
unfortunate position the timing of the
passage of the bill we were able to do a
lot of the initial work with the
executive Council in the gassett phase
and we had made some assumptions based
on the conversations in Congress around
future funding and so while we were
programming additional dollars at the
end of the process we weren't having to
program all of the new money we had been
staying current with what we were
hearing on Capitol Hill so luckily we
have programmed the majority of the
funds so for this committee it's more
about identifying
priorities and moving some things around
we're relieved that the Lion's Share of
the work has been done to at least
establish the core programs and get the
but I think that's it
okay for the members of the committee
who are here or listening I know some of
the ones who are under the weather we're
going to listen in we do meet next week
on Wednesday the 19th in the morning we
hear a couple of uh bills on on
Road usage uh fees
um and we will see what we do with those
and then
um
removing a roll temp roll
uh RAB tool and hook set another loss of
Revenue and establishing a surcharge on
easy pass for electric vehicles all of
which we hear next Wednesday morning and
early afternoon before we get into the
10-year plan
um but I I know that the commissioner
has said that she would have
knowledgeable people sitting in the back
as we go through all of those so that if
there are specific questions that we
would be able to ask the the department
just as we were this morning on on the
railroad so commissioner again I
appreciate your support to the committee
and and the bills as they come through
because without the expertise sitting
there sometimes we could go off in a
direction that would be less desirable
so I will see the committee next week
um think about what we're going to do
um the rail Bill and some of the others
because we do have to exec those bills